ओ
सो वी आर लाइव नाउ थिंक सो लेट्स
चेक सभी चीजें चेक कर लेते हैं पहले ऑडियो
वीडियो सब कुछ तो जल्दी से बता दीजिए गाइस
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू एवरी
बडी गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग सबको राम राम गुड
इवनिंग चलिए तो सभी को आ जाने देते हैं
पहले जल्दी से आ जाने देते हैं सभी लोग आ
जाइए फटाफट आइए फटाफट आइए फटाफट आइए फटाफट
गुड इवनिंग सब क्या हाल चाल है सबके वेलकम
टू द डेट क्या हाल है
सबके बढ़िया आज बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक
करने वाले हैं हम बहुत ही ज्यादा
इंटरेस्टिंग
राइट
बहुत सारी चीज आज करने वाले हैं देखने
वाले हैं सीखने वाले हैं समझने वाले हैं
ओके चलिए तो जल्दी से मुझे बता दीजिए सभी
लोग लेट मी नो एवरी बडी प्लीज ऑडियो
वीडियो सब सही सब मस्त बिंदास चल रहा है
कोई प्रॉब्लम तो नहीं आ रही
है एंड वी विल स्टार्ट नाउ
बढ़िया चलिए मैं यहां पर चेक कर लेता हूं
ओके ओके ओके एथिंग इ
गुड 36 लोग आ चुके हैं य पे जल्दी से सभी
आ जाने देते हैं
सबको एंड वी विल मूव
देन 44 आ गए हैं क्या बात
है बहुत
बढ़िया 50 प्लस होते ही स्टार्ट कर देंगे
हम जैसे हमारा 50 प्लस यहां पर मार्क आ
जाता है व विल स्टार्ट
राइट बाकी सभी लोग लाइक कर दो यार आते आते
लाइक ठोक दिया करो मजा आ जाता है
फिर अब मुझे यह बता
दीजिए न्यू सब्सक्राइबर वेलकम ब्रदर एवरी
न्यू सब्सक्राइबर इज
वेलकम टू दिस एथ
क्लास
एवरीवन सो हेलो एवरीवन दिस इज नितेश फाउंड
एंड वेलकम टू द क्लास एट डे एट ऑफ बग
बाउंट फ्री कोर्स अंडर आवर इनिशिएटिव फ्री
और मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल एजुकेशन फॉर
एवरीबॉडी
वेरी वेरी वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग्स
जो आपको मतलब मजा आ जाएगा देख के ठीक है
सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन हमने पहले वाले क्लास
सेवन में ऑलरेडी किया हुआ था मैंने आपको
बोला था उसका कंटिन्यूएशन आज हम करेंगे
कंटिन्यूएशन और भी डीप घुस और भी बहुत कुछ
करेंगे और एक स्टेप और आगे हम बढ़ेंगे आज
का सेशन मिस बिल्कुल मत करना लाइव में
बहुत मजा आएगा और हो सके तो मेरे साथ-साथ
आप भी करो लाइव काली मशीन आपके पास ऑन
होना चाहिए
दैट्ची टाइम
में मैं देख लेता
हूं मैं यहां पर टाइप कर देता
हूं मैं यहां पर ट में ट चैनल पर सब लोगों
को फिर से टाइप कर देता हूं ओके ठीक है तो
चलिए कितने लोग आ चुके हैं अभी यहां पर
चलिए काफी लोग आ चुके हैं चलिए बढ़िया ओके
ओके ग्रेट चलिए 65 एंड लाइक्स कितने हैं
65 है और लाइक्स है 46 कुछ लोगों ने लाइक
नहीं किया यार अच्छा नहीं लगता उनको शायद
पता नहीं कोई बात नहीं चलेगा मुझे एक सबसे
पहला क्वेश्चन आप सबसे प्लीज जब मैं
क्वेश्चन पूछूं तो आप सभी लोग रेस्पॉन्ड
करना एवरी बडी प्लीज रेस्पों कितने लोगों
ने सब डोमेन न्यूमरेशन वाली टास्क करी सब
डोमेन फाइंड करने की कोशिश करी एंड सब
डोमेन फाइंड किया कई लोगों ने तो
किया हुआ है एंड
दैट्ची ठीक है इन्होंने जैसे टैग किया था
और भी कुछ लोग टैग करते रहते हैं तो ये
दैट्ची हमें पता चल जाएगा कि आपने क्या
किया है कई लोगों ने टास्क किया है उसका
भी टैग किया है कि मैंने यह टास्क किया है
जैसे इन्होंने माय रिपोर्ट करके यह टैग
किया हुआ था तो टास्क का पता चल जाता है
इससे ठीक है तो यह आप काम कर लीजिए और आप
लोग मैं ऐसा उम्मीद करता हूं कि आप लोग
में से सभी लोग टास्क कर रहे हैं एंड सभी
लोग जो मैं बोलता हूं वो चीजें परफॉर्म कर
रहे हैं
राइट चलिए
ओके
पाकिस्तान पेमेंट में प्रॉब्लम आ रही है
ब्रदर आपका इंटरनेशनल डेबिट कार्ड होना
चाहिए पाकिस्तान का या क्रेडिट कार्ड और
इंटरनेशनल पेमेंट इनेबल्ड होना चाहिए तभी
जाके होगा ठीक है
चलिए तो आज हम पता है क्या करने वाले हैं
आज हम बहुत कमाल की चीज करने वाले हैं
बहुत धमाल की चीज करने वाले हैं मैं आपको
पहले दिखा देता हूं आपको थोड़ा सा ओवरव्यू
दे देता हूं आज हम क्या करने वाले हैं
लेट्स हैव सम ओवरव्यू हमने सब डोमेन फाइंड
करा था लास्ट सेशन में हमने ने क्या करा
था सब डोमेन फाइंड करा था हां ठीक है इसके
पहले मैं आपको एक चीज और दिखाना चाहता हूं
जस्ट
वेट इसके पहले मैं आप सबको एक चीज दिखाना
चाहता हूं अभी जैसे सेशन स्टार्ट करने से
पहले हमारा डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक का एक
सर्टिफिकेशन का ट्रेनिंग लाइव ट्रेनिंग
लॉन्च हुआ है आप सबको शायद प पहले से पता
होगा आप सबने वीडियो भी देखी होगी इसका
मैं लिंक भी आपको दे देता हूं अ डिजिटल
फरें सक्स लाइव
ट्रेनिंग इसका मैंने आपको लिंक भी दे दिया
है
ओके सो इसका मैंने आपको लिंक भी दे दिया
है आप चैट में देख लीजिएगा बेसिकली यह
लाइव ट्रेनिंग हमने लच किया है एंड यहां
पे हमने 50 सीट्स रखे हैं एंड इस ट्रेनिंग
में आपको डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक कंप्लीट बिगनर
टू एडवांस लेवल की सिखाई जाएगी आपको को
बताई जाएगी पूरी हैंडसन कराई जाएगी टूल्स
एंड ऑल सब कुछ होगा ए टू जेड होगा तो आप
इस लिंक पे आएंगे तो आपको हमारी इस
ट्रेनिंग के बारे में सारी डिटेल सिलेबस
सब कुछ मिल जाएगा एंड यहीं से आप इनरोल भी
कर सकते हैं आके प्री बुकिंग आपको करनी
होती है
दैट्ची करेंगे ना तो आपको सबसे कम जो फी
दिखेगी इंटरनेट पे डिस्ट ऑफ फंसी की वो
25000 दिखेगी उसको हमने रेगुलर फी जो रखा
उसको किया हमने 14000 बट अभी फर्स्ट बैच
के लिए 7000 का है जिसमें से 3500 ही ओनली
आपको भी करने हैं बाकी रिमेनिंग वन मंथ के
बाद तो अगर आप डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक के फील्ड
को एक्सप्लोर करना चाहते हैं साइबर क्राइम
केसेस को समझने के लिए कुछ स्किल्स गेन
करना चाहते हैं जब आप देखते हैं साइबर सेल
वगैरह साइबर क्राइम्स होते हैं तो वहां पे
डिजिटल फुटप्रिंट्स को एनालाइज करा जाता
है बहुत सारी चीजों को रिकवर किया जाता है
ऐसे डाटा जो इंपॉसिबल टू रिकवर लगते हैं
उनको रिकवर किया जाता है वो सब चीजें करना
चाहते हैं तो यू कैन जॉइन दिस एंड यू कैन
प्रीबुक टू दिस लाइव ट्रेनिंग 27th जन से
ये ट्रेनिंग स्टार्ट होगी क्लास पहली आपकी
27 जन को होगी उसके पहले आप नेक्स्ट वन
वीक तक अगर आप करते हैं तो आप इस ऑफर
प्राइस में 7000 वाले में इनरोल कर पाएंगे
ठीक है तो यह कर लीजिएगा इस पेज पर आ
जाइएगा de.com डिटल h फरेंस हान मास्टरी
आपको यहां पर इसकी पूरी डिटेल मिल जाएगी
चैट में मैंने आपको बता ही दिया है तो चैट
में आपको मिल जाएगी इसकी डिटेल ठीक है
चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते हैं आज का
सेशन
ओके चलिए आज का सेशन स्टार्ट करते हैं
एंड
ओके आज के सेशन में सब डोमेन हमने लास्ट
सेशन में सब डोमेन को इनमेट करा था वी
इमरेड सब डोमेंस अब हम सब डोमेंस के सब
डोमेंस को फाइंड कैसे करेंगे सब डोमेंस ऑफ
सब डोमेंस पहले तो यह काम करेंगे हमने एक
देखा था एसटीटीपी एकस का यूज करके हमने
लाइव सब डोमेंस भी निकाले थे
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग का थोड़ा एग्जांपल
हल्का-फुल्का ले लिया था बट हम और डीप
जाके और क्या-क्या चीजें कर सकते हैं लाइव
बग बाउंट जो हम करेंगे अभी तो लाइव बक्स
फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे किसी
पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन में किसी पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट में तब जाकर थोड़ा मजा आएगा शायद
हमें है ना तो आज वह काम करने वाले हैं तो
एकदम बिल्कुल एकदम से दिमाग को ओपन करके
रखिए एंड ध्यान दीजिए आज के इस सेशन पे
चलिए सबसे पहले
मैं ब क्राउड को ओपन कर लेता हूं वी विल
ओपन द ब क्राउड हियर
एंड प्रोग्राम्स पर चलते
हैं आप में से जो भी साथ में करना चा आते
हैं यू कैन
शली यू कैन ट्राई दिस लॉग आउट कर देते हैं
कोई बात नहीं लो लॉग आउट में क्यों कर रहा
हूं आई
थिंक रिसर्चर चलते हैं रिसर्चर पे एंड
यहां पे लॉग इन करने की कोशिश करते हैं अश
डला 13 यहां पे एक मेल आईडी डाल देता हूं
मैं पासवर्ड डाल के देखता हूं यह पासवर्ड
है या नहीं है लेट्स
सी आई थिंक पासवर्ड इज करेक्ट
या एब्सलूट करेक्ट चलिए तो यहां पे गाइस
हम प्रोग्राम्स पे आ जाएंगे वेलकम टू द
प्रोग्राम सेक्शन ठीक है प्रोग्राम सेक्शन
में आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको प्रोग्राम की
लिस्ट मिलेगी आप सबको पता है यहां से आप
टारगेट चूज कर सकते हैं जो भी टारगेट चाहे
जो मर्जी आपकी टारगेट चाहे आप चूज कीजिए
व्हाट एवर यू वांट वो आपकी मर्जी है बट
मैं आपको पहले ही बोल चुका हूं ना एक
अच्छे टारगेट चूज करके आपको वैलिड बग
मिलने के चांसेस ज्यादा होते हैं जब अच्छे
टारगेट चूज करेंगे वैलिड बग मिलने के
ज्यादा चांसेस होते हैं अब एक बात मुझे
बताइए एक बात मुझे बताइए मैंने आपसे पहले
ही बोला हुआ था एक डोमेन है
लेंस काड कॉ मान लो इसका एक सब डोमेन है
हेल्प डॉलेंस
कॉ अब इसका भी एक सब सब डोमेन है डेव
डॉट स्टग डॉट लेंस काड कॉ यह करके अब इसका
भी एक सब सब डोमेन है कॉर्प डॉट डेव डॉट
स्टैग डॉट ये बस एग्जांपल के लिए है इसको
ज्यादा सीरियस आपको नहीं लेना है ये
एग्जांपल्स को ठीक
है ये आपके सब डोमेंस है तो हमें ये सारे
सब डोमेंस जो है वो फाइंड करने हैं हमारा
टारगेट वही होना चाहिए टू फाइंड एव्री सब
डोमेन वी कैन गैदर मैंने आपको तरीके बताए
थे मैंने आपको सब लिस्टर आपको बताया था
टूल सब लिस्टर सब फाइंडर आपको बताया था ए
मैस आपको बहुत सारे
जो टूल्स है वो ऑलरेडी आपको बताए थे देखिए
सॉरी तो अब हम आज से स्टार्ट करते हैं एक
कोई एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट ले लेते हैं अगर
आपके दिमाग में आपके मन में कोई टारगेट है
आपके ध्यान में कोई टारगेट है तो मुझे आप
चैट में बता दीजिए मुझे चैट में बता दीजिए
कोई टारगेट है तो लेट मी नो इन द चैट किसी
के पास कोई टारगेट है डोमेन टारगेट हम
इसमें से भी फाइंड कर सकते हैं बढ़िया
टारगेट कोई तो चलिए एक बार देख लेते हैं
कोई भी टारगेट
बल
ओके पेज 10 पर चलते
हैं क्या स्टैक डॉट हेल्प
होगा अरे कोई सा भी मैं डोमेन बोल रहा हूं
भाई कोई सा भी डोमेन ले सकते हो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं
है टाडिया उसको ओपन कर लेते
हैं
आई रोबोट लेट्स सी दिस आई
रोबोट कुछ खास इनके है नहीं डोमेन तो इसको
रिमूव कर देते हैं इस कुछ खास डोमेन नहीं
है इनपुट में यहां पर भी कुछ खास हमारे
पास वाइल्ड कार्ड एंट्रीज वाले नहीं हम
वाइड काड एंट्री डोमेन को लेंगे ट्रिप
एडवाइजर इ देयर वी कैन गेट इनटू दिस ट्रिप
एडवाइजर यहां पर शायद इनके टारगेट अच्छे
होंगे मेरे ख्याल से ठीक है इस पर भी जा
सकते हैं बट नो वाइल्ड कार्ड
फाइंडिंग ओके
[संगीत]
इसका बक बाउंट प्रोग्राम कैसा है रिवर्ट्स
प्रोग्राम ठीक है
ओके स्पेसिफिक डोमेन कुछ ऐसा यहां प
samsung.com
या दिस इज द डोमेन samsung.com सो वी कैन
गो फॉर samsung.com ऑब् वियस राइट तो
चलिए चलिए samsung.com को हम टारगेट ले
लेते हैं आज के लिए एंड इनका बक बाउंट
प्रोग्राम है तो देर इज नथिंग टू वरी
अबाउट राइट तो चलिए सबसे पहले आपको थोड़ा
सा पहले थोड़ा पीछे लेके चलते हैं एंड देन
वी विल ट्राई टू अंडरस्टैंड राइट चलिए मैं
यहां पे टर्मिनल ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड यहां
मैं इसको जूम जूम कर देता हूं सबसे पहले
वी आर गोइंग टू यूज सब फाइंडर जैसा कि
मैंने आपको बताया था सब फाइंडर हम यूज
करने वाले हैं सब फाइंडर का हमने कॉन्फिन
कर दिया था कहां से कन्फेशन किया था
भैया यहां पे हम गए थे अ होम डायरेक्टरी
में होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में यहां पे
कॉन्फिन फिग में आने पे हमें सब फाइंडर
नाम का एक डायरेक्टरी दिखा था एंड इसमें
ये प्रोवाइडर कॉन्ग डवा एए है इसमें हमने
तीन एपीआई कीज कंफिल करी थी हम इस तीन
एपीआई की के भरोसे ही अपना काम यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए कर रहे हैं बट कैसे कर रहे
हैं देखो अभी अभी देखो सबसे पहले सब
फाइंडर हमें यूज करना है हमें नहीं पता
भाई क्या होता है सब फाइंडर कैसे यूज करना
है हाईनेस देना है बात खत्म हमें कभी नहीं
पता क्या कैसे यूज करना है भाई तुमको
सीखना है तुम्हें खुद से यूज करना सीखना
है ऐसे नहीं स्पून फीडिंग वाला काम को या
के चमच से खिला दे भाई चम इजली बता दे है
ना चलो तो
अब यहां पे कैसे करना है h डी देना है
डोमस टू फाइंड सब डोमस फॉर h डी हमें दे
देना है तो चलिए
samsung.com हमने ये टारगेट मेंशन कर दिया
अब कौन-कौन से आर्गुमेंट आपको लगाने हैं
या फ्लैग्स लगाने हैं ये देख लीजिए सोर्स
के लिए स्पेसिफिक सोर्स आपको मेंशन करना
है नहीं भाई सभी चाहिए ऑल यहां पे सारे
सोर्सेस को नरेट करेगा हान ऑल लगा देने से
तो हम हान ऑल लगा देते हैं सारे सोर्सेस
को तुम इनमेट कर लो लेके बहुत बढ़िया उसके
बाद नीचे आ जाते हैं
एंड और कुछ नहीं है आउटपुट के लिए हान आप
लगा सकते हैं बढ़िया है कॉन्फिन ऑटोमेटिक
डिटेक्ट कर लेगा तो कोई जरूरत नहीं है
साइलेंट ऑप्शन लगा सकते हैं शो ओनली सब
डोमस इन आउटपुट ओनली सब डोमस के लिए हान
साइलेंट लगा सकते हैं तो हान साइलेंट भी
लगा देते हैं एंड यहां पे अब क्या करने
वाले हैं हम h o लगा के एंड यहां पे
हमें किसी चीज की जरूरत मुझे नहीं लगती है
टाइम आउट वगैरह आप लगा सकते हैं इफ यू
वांट अदर वाइज ऐसे कोई जरूरत नहीं है हमें
एंड
दैट्ची है रिजॉल्वर्स लगा सकते हैं बट अभी
जरूरत नहीं है हमें हमें इतना करके अब हम
क्या करते हैं
samsung.com को ग्रैब कर लेगा आपके कमांड
जो है सक्सेसफुली कंप्लीट हो जाएगी एंड
आपके पास एक फाइल होगी
samsung.com हैं इंडिविजुअली वो आपके मिल
जाएंगे चलिए सो लेट्स वेट फॉर द
रिजल्ट हान v नहीं लगाएंगे आप हान v जब आप
हान साइलेंट लगाएंगे तो यू कैन नॉट यूज़
हान v इसका मैं एक कारण बता देता हूं हान
v का मतलब होता है वर्वस आउटपुट आपको शो
करता है वह वर्वस जो भी आउटपुट है ना सारे
डीबगिंग इंफो की तरह आपको शो करता है सारी
चीजें जिससे आप डीबगर सकते हैं या देख
सकते हैं आउटपुट्स को जब हाइन साइलेंट लगा
दिया तो आपने ऑलरेडी इंस्ट्रक्ट कर दिया
है इस कमांड को इस टूल को कि आप सिर्फ सब
डोमस दिखा दिखाओ तो बाकी आउटपुट तो दिखाने
का कोई सवाल नहीं उठता तो यह कंट्रा इक्ट
करेगा अगर दोनों कमांड दोनों स्विचेउ यूज़
करेंगे तो तो यहां पे फिलहाल आपका
फाइल देखने के लिए और डलसी हान ए
वर्डलिस्ट काउंट करने के लिए तो 2307 सब
डोमेंस इसने फाइंड कर दिए
सब फाइंडर इज वन ऑफ द बेस्ट टूल यह यकीन
करके रखो तो आप आपके ऊपर है आपकी मर्जी है
वह सारी चीजें आप सब डोमेन फाइंड करने
केलिए सब फाइंडर यूज कर लो कोई और भी यूज
करलो सबको कंबाइन करो ये आपकी मर्जी है
ठीक है फिलहाल मैं सब फाइंडर यूज कर रहा
हूं
चलिए अब हमारे पास सब डोमेंस तो आ गई अब
मुझे सब डोमेंस
को सब डोमेंस के सब डोमेंस को फाइंड करना
है बड़ी बात यह है अब वी हैव टू फाइंड सब
डोमस ऑफ सब डोम समझ में आ रहा है सब लोगों
को चैट में जल्दी बता दीजिए जल्दी जल्दी
जल्दी जल्दी एवरीवन टेल मी जल्दी
बताइए आर यू गेटिंग एवरीवन समझ में आ रहा
है सब डोमस के सब डोमस को हमें फाइंड करना
है मुझे बता दीजिए मैं फोन पर देख रहा हूं
आप लोगों का बताइए आई एम सीइंग द फोन टेल
मी चैट देख रहा हूं मैं जल्दी बता
दीजिए
ओके ठीक है ठीक है तो अब हमें 2307 सब
डोमेंस यहां पे मिल चुके हैं अब मुझे क्या
चाहिए गाइस कि मुझे और भी सब सब डोमस के
सब डोमेंस अगर फाइंड करने हैं तो उसके
देखो एक मैं आपको एक बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
बताता हूं बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग एक तरीका एफएफ
यूएफ का यूज करके आप कर सकते हैं उसके
अलावा भी आप एक और चीज कर सकते हैं उससे
भी आप सब डोमेंस फाइंड कर सकते हैं बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग वे है चलिए एक टूल बताता हूं
आपको बहुत शानदार टूल है ये टूल आपको बहुत
लोग नहीं बताएंगे बट एक टूल मैं आपको
बताता हूं दैट इज अ वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल
चलिए दिखाता हूं मैं
आपको नाउ दिस टूल
इज वन फॉर
ल गिट हब पर चलते हैं गिट हब पर यह एक टूल
है वन फॉर ऑल टूल ठीक है यह एक टूल है वन
फॉर ऑल बेसिकली यह जो टूल है यह
चाइनीज रेकन टूल है ठीक है य चाइनीज रेकन
टूल है पहली बात चाइनीज टूल है तो चाइनीज
टूल हम यूज करने वाले हैं करना पड़ेगा
करना कर सकते हैं अभी बहुत अपडेटेड टूल है
अभी
यह ऑन द प्रोडक्शन फेज मतलब अभी फेज में
है अभी भी ये तो आप इसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है काफी ज्यादा
यूज़फुल टूल है मैं क्यों यूज़फुल बता रहा
हूं इसका जब हम इंग्लिश डॉक्यूमेंट पे ज
इंग्लिश डॉक्यूमेंट पे क्लिक कर देंगे तो
यहां पे हम आएंगे इंग्लिश डॉक्यूमेंट पे
ठीक है तो ये टूल है वन फॉर
ऑल ओके इंग्लिश डॉक्यूमेंट पे आते हैं वन
फॉर ऑल इज अ पावरफुल सब डोमेन इंटीग्रेशन
टूल सब डोमेन इंटीग्रेशन टूल है नीचे आ
जाते हैं यहां पे अब यहां गाइज जब इसके
तुम फीचर्स को देखोगे तो तुम्हारा दिमाग
हिल जाएगा लिटरली इट विल ब्लोन अवे मतलब
योर माइंड विल बी ब्लोन अवे अब क्या है
यहां पे सब डोमेंस को निकालने के लिए ठीक
है यह क्या-क्या यूज़ करता है छह
सर्टिफिकेट मॉड्यूल यूज़ करता है सेंसेस
सर्च स्पॉटर सर्च सेच इंटरेस्ट google2
एपीआई सिक्स बेसलाइन टेस्टिंग मॉड्यूस यूज
करता है दो वेब क्रॉलर मॉड्यूल यूज़ करता
है 24 डीएनएस डेटा सेट मॉड्यूल यूज करता
है यहां पे सिक्स डीएनएस क्वेरीज मॉड्यूल
यूज़ करता है सिक्स थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
मॉड्यूल यूज़ करता है सोल सर्च इंजन
मॉड्यूल यूज़ करता है सब डोमेन ब्रूट
फोर्स को सपोर्ट करता है सब डोमेन
वेरिफिकेशन को क्रॉ इंग को रिप्लेसमेंट को
टेक ओवर को सब चीज इसमें आपका इंक्लूडेड
है एवरीथिंग इज इंक्लूडेड इनसाइड दिस वन
टूल वन फॉर
ऑल ठीक
है समझ में आ रहा है ये इंग्लिश वाली टूल
है अब इसको तो हम अभी देखेंगे बट इसको
देखने से पहले हम एक और टूल का देखेंगे
पहले इंटरेस्टिंग चीज एक और टूल का
देखेंगे एंड वो चीज वो जो टूल है वो है ए
एफ यू एफ यह टूल क्या है एफ एफ यूएफ चलिए
अब एफ एफ यूएफ को कैसे देखना है कैसे इसका
यूज करना है पहले हम इसको समझते हैं चलिए
एफएफ यूएफ के गिट हब रिपोजिटरी पर चल देते
हैं पहले
हम सॉरी एफफ यूफ के गिट रिपोजिटरी प जाओगे
तो यहां पर य यहां पर आपको दिखेगा वी
होस्ट डिस्कवरी वाला जो वो है यहां पर आप
आएंगे तो विदाउट डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड में ओस
डिस्कवरी आपको करनी है तो कुछ इस तरीके से
आप कर सकते हैं बट इसका एक सिंपल सा तरीका
क्या है मैं आपको यह चीज बता देता हूं सब
डोमेंस फाइंड करने का एंड उसको हम फाइंड
करके ट्राई करेंगे देखने का बट उसके पहले
हमारे पास एक अच्छी वर्डलिस्ट होनी चाहिए
सब डोमेंस फाइंड करने की सबसे बड़ी बात यह
है एक अच्छी वर्ड लिस्ट होगी तो अ अच्छा
रिजल्ट आपको देखने को मिलेगा तो एफएफ यूएफ
से भी हम
[संगीत]
samsungfunclubs.com ने दे देंगे एंटर कर
देंगे
दैट्ची कलराइज्ड आउटपुट के लिए मैंने न c
दे दिया न u से डोमेन आपको मेंशन कर देना
है तो हम डोमेन यहां पे दे देते हैं अ
एटीपीए
कॉलन
www.samsung.com यह मान लो आपने क्या दिया
आपने इसका डोमेन दे दिया तो हमने डोमेन तो
भैया दे दिया चलिए यहां पे थोड़ा सा ऐड आ
गया है तो हम थोड़ा सा रुक जाते हैं ऐड के
लिए व विल
स्टॉप ठीक है तो हमने यहां पे डोमेन तो दे
दिया एटीपीएस होगा ना ये एटीपीए सभी लोग
देख पा रहे हैं ठीक है
https.com यहां हमने डोमेन दे दिया अब
यहां पे हमें हान वर्डलिस्ट डब् नड यहां
पे बताना है वर्डलिस्ट हमें एक वर्ड लिस्ट
चाहिए जिससे कि हम सब डोमेन को ब्रूट
फोर्स कर पाएंगे तो अब ये देखिए यहां पे न
ये रहा नड तो अब यह सब डो न के ब्रूट
फोर्स करने के लिए वर्ड लिस्ट कहां से
आएगी भाई तो वर्ड लिस्ट आप अलग-अलग वर्ड
लिस्ट निकाल सकते हैं सब डोमेन ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग के लिए देर आर मल्टीपल वर्ड
लिस्ट अवेलेबल जैसे कि मैंने आपको पहले भी
बताया था देख लीजिए यहां
पे एन0 के ओओ इनका वड लिस्ट है नो कोवो
करके जो भी आप बोले यहां पे सो ही जज अ
वेरी गुड इंटरेस्टिंग वर्ड लिस्ट फॉर सब
डोमेन तो आप नीचे आएंगे नोको वड लिस्ट
यहां पर आपको मिल जाएगी ठीक
है नोको सब डोमस वाली रिपोजिटरी मिले आपको
इसमें इनकी वर्डलिस्ट जो है व मिल जाएगी
यह सारे सब डोमेंस की आप यहां से यह ले
सकते हैं उसके बाद आप सेक लिस्ट से भी सब
डोमेंस की वर्डलिस्ट निकाल सकते हैं सेक
लिस्ट पे आप जाएंगे सेक लिस्ट
पे सब डोमस के लिए वर्ड लिस्ट निकाल सकते
हैं अ डिस्कवरी में चलते हैं डिस्कवरी में
आ जाते हैं डीएनएस को एक्सपेंड करते हैं
एंड डीएनएस पे आएंगे तो यहां पे ये रहेगा
बिट कर्क सब डोमेन बग बाउंट पैरम अ यहां
पे न कोवो भी यहां पे आपको मिल ही जा रहा
है नोको भी सब डोमेन यहां पे आपको मिल रहा
है अ लाइक डीएनएस के अंदर में ट्स ग्रेट
ठीक है नेम लिस्ट यहां पे आ गया सब डोमेन
सब डोमेन स्टॉप 1 मिलियन ऐसे करके आ रहा
है कोई भी सब डोमेन आप यूज कर लीजिए
फिलहाल के लिए मैं क्या करता हूं मैं
हमारे पास सिस्टम में यूएसआर यूएसआर
सिस्टम में ही अवेलेबल है ठीक है तो हम
नोको वाला यूज कर लेते हैं नोको विस करके
जो है ना एक कौन सी है कहां गई यहां प
ऑलरेडी हमारे पास है ये ये नोको वो
सबलिस्ट करके ये वाली कितनी है टोटल ये
एंट्रीज कितने हैं इसको देख लेते हैं बहुत
सारे हैं यार बहुत सारे एंट्रीज है इसको
हम एक बार देख लेते हैं कैट एन ओ के एंड
सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी ओके डब् सी हान एल एंड 50 5 लाख 5
लाख है बहुत है यार बहुत है 5 लाख के
आसपास है हम इसी को यूज करने वाले हैं
राइट वी विल यूज दिस सो हम ड एन ओ के सॉरी
एन ओ नो कोवी हमने ये यूज कर लिया बट अब
यहां पे हम फज लगाएंगे हम यहां पे फज कर
रहे हैं ठीक है राइट हम फज कर रहे हैं सब
डोमस के लिए तो हम यहां पे जो कीवर्ड
लगाएंगे f यड ए ज यह वाला कीवर्ड हम लगा
देंगे ठीक है f
u.s.c. थिंग के लिए तो डिफॉल्ट जो है इसका
200 से 299 301 302 ये सारे डिफॉल्ट इसके
हैं जो आपको प्रोवाइड करता है बट फिलहाल
के लिए मुझे क्या चाहिए मुझे चाहिए न एसी
लगा देता हूं मुझे 200 वाला चाहिए जो ओके
हो चलता हो काम करता हो एंड आप 404 भी लगा
सकते हैं लाइक सब डोमेन अ टेक ओवर के लिए
हम इसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं बट फिलहाल के
लिए 200 रहने देते हैं सब डोमेन टेक ओवर
जब हम करेंगे तो उस समय हम ये चीज देखने
वाले हैं ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है तो ये
चीजें हमने कर ली samsung.com अब ये तो
हमने काम कर लिया अब अब इसमें आप थोड़ा सा
इसकी स्पीड को बढ़ा सकते हो यहां पे एक
आपको अ
दिखेगा फ्लैग लेट्स सी अ लेट्स सी रेट हान
रेट रेट ऑफ रिक्वेस्ट पर सेकंड डिफॉल्ट
जीरो है तो इसकी रेट को थोड़ा बढ़ा सकते
हो हाइफ रेट लगा के मैं इसको 100 कर देता
हूं थोड़ा फास्ट कर देता हूं रेट स्पीड को
फास्ट कर देता हूं
दैट्ची
इफ इट इज ऑफ यूज वी कैन मेंशन
यस हाइन व यहां पे आप लगा सकते हो वर्वस
मोड के लिए बट स्टिल अभी के लिए हम इतना
रहने देते हैं इतना मोर दन सफिशिएंट है
आपके पास एंड हम इसको एंटर करते हैं एंटर
करने के साथ ही गाइस इट विल स्टार्ट
गिविंग यू ऑल द सब डोमन दैट इट गट थ्रू द
वर्ड लिस्ट जो वर्ड लिस्ट है वहां से सब
डोमेन उठा के आपको ये दे रहा है ठीक है
वहां से ये यूनिक सब डोमस आपके बना के ये
आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा है जैसे आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे अब ये जो है ना ये सिर्फ ये
इस तरीके से शो कर रहा है अब इसका मैं
आपको हाइन v वाला फॉर्मेट दिखा देता हूं
हाइन v लगा देते हैं वर्वस मोड के लिए
व्हाट इज
दिस ओके हाइन v स्मॉल होगा शायद हां तो
हाइन v हमने लगा दिया अब हम जब हाइन v लगा
देंगे ना तो यह देखो अब क्या
होगा देखो किस तरीके से शो करेगा ये देख
रहे हो पूरा पूरा आपको यूआरएल शो करेगा
हाइन व जब आप लगा दोगे तो पूरी फुल यूआरएल
आपको देखनी है तो हाइन व लगा दोगे तो आपको
यहां प फुल यूआरएल जो भी ये सब डोमेंस को
इमरेड करेगा वो आपको सब डोमेंस यहां पे
फाइंड करके दिखा देगा ये समझ में आ रहा है
ये इतना इजी टू अंडरस्टैंड है कोई ज्यादा
कॉम्प्लेक्टेड है वो ठीक है यू विल गेट टू
अंडरस्टैंड दैट जस्ट वेट एंड
वच जस्ट इंतजार कीजिए और
देखिए ये आपको रिजल्ट शो कर रहा
है ठीक है बहुत सारे हैं यह बहुत सारे हैं
रिजल्ट्स आपको शो करेगा यह आपके सब डोमेन
से है इसको अगर आप किसी फाइल आउटपुट फाइल
में डालना चाहते हैं तो आउटपुट फाइल में
आप डाल दीजिए हान ओ करके इट विल बी आउटपुट
यहां पे ठीक है यहां पे यह हान डी लगाएगा
मैच रिजल्ट्स को कर यहां पे आउटपुट फाइल
में डालेगा यहां पे एंड किसी पर्टिकुलर
फॉर्मेट में आउटपुट चाहिए आपको तो एक
पर्टिकुलर फॉर्मेट में य आपके आउटपुट जो
है वो आके आ जाएगा ठीक है चलिए ये सारी
चीज आप ये सारे जो रिक्वेस्ट वगैरह है
रिक्वेस्ट वगैरह देखने के लिए आप कर सकते
हैं अदर वाइज आप इसको छोड़ सकते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है यहां पे कुछ एक्सक्लूड
एचटीटीपी स्टेटस कोड्स को फिल्टर आउट करना
हो या एक्सक्लूड करना हो तो य आप ये सारे
कमांड्स भी यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है तो
यहां पे ये आपको यहां पे इस तरीके से ये
सारी चीजें जो है वो दे देगा चलिए यहां पे
कुछ एरर्स यहां पे आ रहे हैं यहां पे बाकी
एरर्स आ रहे हैं बाकी आप इसको रहने
दीजिएगा एंड ये आपको रिजल्ट्स देता है तो
इस तरीके से ये पर्टिकुलर एनालाइज करने के
लिए आप एफएफ यूएफ जैसी चीज जो है टूल जो
है वो यूज कर सकते हैं एनालिसिस के लिए आप
यूज कर सकते हैं बहुत बढ़िया होता है ये
तो आपको समझ में आ गया एफएफ यूएफ की कमाल
अब आते हैं एक और इंटरेस्टिंग चीज पे
जिसको हम बोलते हैं सब डोमेन का भी सब
डोमेन फाइंड करना कर सकते हैं बट उसके
पहले हम यूज करेंगे वन फॉर ऑल वन फॉर ऑल
का यूज बहुत ही शानदार है आप उससे मल्टीपल
सब डोमस फाइंड कर सकते हैं चलिए हम पहले
उसको देख लेते हैं एक बार समझते हैं बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है गाइस यह टूल आपको
जल्दी कोई बताएगा नहीं क् एक चाइनीज टूल
है एंड काफी ज्यादा रिसर्चर जो है ना इसको
ऑलरेडी यूज करते हैं बिलीव मी बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है इसको आप देखो यहां पे
ध्यान से देखना इसको प्रैक्टिस जरूर
करना नहीं लैपटॉप का ही कीबोर्ड है लेट हो
आई एम लेट लेट क्यों है भाई लेट नहीं होना
है जितने लोग हैं यहां एकदम दिमाग खोल के
बैठ जाइए एकदम
एंड प्लीज कोई भी स्पैम नहीं करना है
स्पैम करोगे तो मैं आपको टाइम आउट में डाल
दूंगा ठीक है चलिए वन फॉर ऑल को इंस्टॉल
कैसे करना है मैं आपको यह भी दिखा देता
हूं आपको समझा देता हूं यहां पे वेयर इट
इज वन फॉर ऑल वन फॉर
ऑल बहुत लोग इसको यूज कर रहे हैं गाइस
वेरी वेरी पावरफुल एंड वेरी वेरी यूजफुल
टूल तो यह वाला इसका गेटअप रिपोजिटरी है
आपको इसको सिंपली क्लोन कर लेना है ठीक है
आपको क्लोन कर लेना है देखो यहां प
इंस्टॉलेशन का प्रोसेस भी यहां पे बता रखा
होगा ये रहा
डॉक्स डॉक्स में
होगा हां इंग्लिश वाली यहां पे
है रिलीजस चेंज
रिकॉर्ड
हां यह रहा इसका यह रहा इंस्टॉलेशन
स्टेप्स फॉर गिट हब के लिए यहां पे आप
आएंगे तो यहां पे गिट क्लोन कर लेना है
आपको इंस्टॉलेशन के लिए फिर उसके बाद
python3 हान पिन यह कमांड लगा देना है
रिक्वायरमेंट्स को इंस्टॉल कर लेनी है
सेटिस्फाई कर लेना है एंड देन आपको इसको
स्टार्ट कर लेना है ठीक है बस स्टार्ट
करने के बाद इसको आप कैसे यूज करेंगे कैसे
आपको कमांड्स डालने हैं आप नीचे आएंगे
यहां पे तो यहां पे आपको दिखेगा
इंस्ट्रक्शन वन फॉर ऑल यूसेज यूसेज में
आएंगे तो आपको इस तरीके से यूज करना है एक
सिंपल एक पर्टिकुलर टा ट का भी आप सब
डोमेन फाइंड करके सारा लिस्ट निकाल सकते
हैं या आपके पास अगर लिस्ट है टारगेट्स की
बहुत सारे टारगेट्स की सब डोमेन फाइंड
करने हैं तो आप यह काम कर सकते हो
टारगेट्स में लेके एग्जांपल ड t जो भी
आपके डायरेक्टरी में जो भी आपके डोमस है
उन सब की एक साथ भी आप निकाल सकते हो
फिलहाल हमारे पास एक
इसके अंदर एलएस करता हूं बहुत सारी फाइल्स
हैं व फॉर ऑड पवा हमारे एग्जीक्यूटेबल
फाइल भी यहां पड़ा हुआ है इसको यूज कैसे
करेंगे python3 एंड वन फॉर ऑल पवाई एंड
दैट्ची samsung.com ओके सो वी हैव
samsung.com टारगेट के अंदर में एंड हमें
इसको रन कर देना है देखो ये कितनी
इंटरेस्टिंग आपको रिजल्ट देगा आपका दिमाग
हिल जाएगा मैं एंटर करता हूं एंड इट विल
स्टार्ट वर्किंग यह अपना काम करना शुरू कर
देगा अब ये देखो तुम हैकर वाली फीलिंग ना
आ जाए तो बताना यह देखो ये देखो कैसे क्या
कर रहा है देखो पहली
बात वन डोमेन ठीक है वन डोमेन कोई बात
नहीं वन डोमेन नीचे आ जाओ सब लिस्टर का भी
यूज कर रहा है सब लिस्टर टूल का बढ़िया है
डीएनएस स्कैन ओके
बढ़िया नीचे आ
जाओ यांडेक्स सर्च स्पॉटर मा स्कल कररी
याहू सर्च सीआरटीएस क्वेरी ठीक है बढ़िया
नीचे आ जाओ बाय दू ओके ग सर्च बाय दू सर्च
23 सब डोम इसको इससे मिले यहां
से एलियन वल्ट यूआरएल स्कैन साइट मैप
अनुबिस रोबोट चेक रोट की बात हो रही है
हैकर टारगेट ग क्वेरी नेट क्राफ्ट सारे
ठीक है साइट मैप उसको भी वहां से भी निकाल
रहा है वायरस टोटल थ्रेट माइनर वहां से भी
निकाल रहा है आस्क सर्च एंड वेबैक मशीन से
भी निकालेगा
ये ओके यहां पे अब यहां पे आपको अलग-अलग
मिल रहे है यहां पे देखो कोई कोई जैसे
अलर्ट मिल रहा है तो यहां पे कुछ एक साइड
डोजर करके ऑडिट करके अलर्ट आया है कोई बात
नहीं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं अलर्ट वाली
वेबसाइट से आप देख सकते हो हालांकि यह कुछ
है नहीं चलिए यहां पे हां एक अलर्ट में
अलट में जैसे कुछ वेबसाइट्स आ रही है आपके
प्लीज चेक वेदर 1378 samsung.com इज
करेक्ट तो इस वेबसाइट को पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट को आप चेक कर सकते हैं हो सकता है
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग आपको यहां पे मिल जाए इस
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन पे इसलिए यह अलर्ट दे रहा
है क्योंकि यहां पे यह सस्पिशंस
डायरेक्टरी बूट फोर्स करके देखेंगे उस
टाइम पे क्या हमें रिजल्ट मिलता है इस पे
पर्टिकुलर पे अब यह देखिए यहां पे यहां
देख रहे हैं आप यह ब्रूट फर्सिंग स्टार्ट
कर रहा है यह देखो भाई मैं बता रहा हूं
यहां पे जनरेटिंग डिक्शनरी फॉर
samsung.com ठीक है डिक्शनरी साइज़ 9524 7
का डिक्शनरी साइज़ यहां पे जनरेट हुई है
और इस अब ब्रूट फोर्स कर रहा है सब डोमस
पे यह ब्रूट फोर्स भी करता है मतलब सब
डोमेन इनमेट भी करेगा ब्रूट फोर्स भी
करेगा सब चीज कर देगा भाई आपको कुछ करना
ही नहीं है चलो बढ़िया अच्छी बात है अब
यहां पे ये स्टार्ट कर दिया इसने अब ये
परसेंटेज आप देख रहे हैं रिक्वेस्ट जनरेट
कर रहा है यूआरएल के गैदर करने के लिए
इसने स्टार्ट किया है 2 पर अभी हुआ है ये
100% होगा फिर उसके बाद और भी जो भी ये
रिक्वेस्ट मतलब जितने भी ये गैदर कर सकता
है वो ट्राई करेगा गैदर करने का फाउंड 129
सब डोमस ऑफ samsung.com यहां पे लिखा है
इसने कि 129 सब डोमेंस इसने अभी फिलहाल के
लिए फाइंड किए हैं चलिए कोई बात नहीं
अच्छी बात है 129 सब डोमस फाइंड किए हैं
इसके अलावा भी और भी करेगा ये बहुत सारी
चीजें करेगा एंड आपको फिर ये रिजल्ट लाके
देगा तो हमें अब वेट करना पड़ेगा उसके
अलावा कोई ऑप्शन नहीं है ठीक है तो ये
थोड़ा सा स्लो चल रहा है कोई बात नहीं
इसको चलने देते हैं कोई कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है इसको थोड़ा सा साइड में कर देते हैं अब
मुझे ये बताइए आप सब सब लोग आप मुझे सब
लोग बताइए सब लोग बताइए मजा आ रहा है कि
नहीं आ रहा है हां सीपीयू यूसेज बहुत हाई
पे है बट स्टिल मैं आपको अपना सीपीयू बता
देता हूं रम यूसेज बता देता हूं देख लो
अभी फिलहाल के लिए कितना रम क्या यूज हो
रहा होगा यहां चलते हैं रम पे एंड तुम देख
रहे होगे यहां पे मेमोरी जो है 49 पर यूज
हो रही है सीपीयू 20
3.1 ये देखो सीपीयू का जो स्पीड देखो अभी
3.13 3.12 गगा हर्ज इस स्पीड प अभी ये चल
रहा है मेमोरी देखो यहां
पे ये देख रहे हो मेमोरी कितनी यूज हो रही
है भाई 15.6 जीब ऑलमोस्ट यूज हो रही है
आपकी ऑलमोस्ट मतलब आपकी यूज हो रही है
15.6 तो मेमोरी भी यूज हो रहा है आपका
एविया हमारा हमारा ग्राफिक्स कार्ड ये 26
पर के आसपास यूज हो रहा है समझ में आ रहा
है ये कॉन्फिन होनी चाहिए आपके पास अच्छी
तब जाके आपका जो यह सब चीज है ना थोड़ा सा
सही से हो भी पाएगा कर पाओगे राइट समझ में
आ रहा
है मजा आ रहा है क्या बात है ये आप देख
रहे हो यहां पे ये ये जनरेट करेगा और उसके
बाद आपको रिजल्ट देगा थोड़ा सा यहां पे ये
टाइम लेगा कोई बात नहीं कोई टेंशन लेने
वाली बात नहीं है हम दूसरे वाले टैब में
तब तक चलते हैं उसको होने देते हैं ये जो
भैया है हमारे पास ये होने देते हैं तब तक
हम दूसरे सॉरी या तब तक हम दूसरे वाले टैब
में चलते
हैं ओके तो हम इस टाप में आ चुके हैं अब
ये अपना काम कर रहा है अब जब हमारे पास सब
डोमेंस की लिस्ट भैया आ जाएंगी लेट्स सपोज
हमारे पास सारे सब डोमस की लिस्ट आ गए तो
अब हमारे पास क्या है हमें उनको ब्रूट
फोर्स करके हमें सब डोमेंस के भी सब
डोमेंस फाइंड करने हैं
हमें उन पर फर्द ब्रूट फोर्स करना है वव
टू फाइंड सम मोर सब डोमेन ऐसा हमें कुछ
करना है एंड इसी के लिए हमारे पास एक टूल
है जो बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है जिसका नाम
है शफल डीएनएस चलिए य भी मैं आपको दिखा
देता प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी का ही टूल है यह
शफल डीएनएस शफल डीएनएस जो है आप इसको जब
ओपन करोगे तो यहां लिखा हुआ है मास डीएनएस
रपर टू ब्रूट फोर्स एंड रिजॉल्व द सब
डोमेन विथ वाइल्ड कार्ड हैंडलिंग
सपोर्ट डीस का ये फॉक है एक तरह का एंड
इसको चलाने के लिए मास डी डीएनएस नाम की
टूल आपके अंदर इंस्टॉल होनी चाहिए काली के
अंदर मास डीएनएस का है मास डीएनएस गेट
हब
सॉरी यहां पर आएंगे तो मास डीएनएस क्या है
हाई परफॉर्मेंस डीएनएस स्ट्रब रिजॉल्वर
रिजॉल्वर एक तरह का डीस रिजॉल्वर टेस्टिंग
दोज सक्स टू रिजॉल्व मैसिव अमाउंट ऑफ
डोमेन नेम्स इन द ऑर्डर ऑफ मिलियंस ऑफ
बिलियस बहुत फास्ट रिजल्ट आपको देता
है
ठीक है इसी का ये फॉक है सफल डीएन जो आपके
काम को आसान बना देता है हम इसको भी यूज
करने वाले हैं इसको भी हम देखने वाले हैं
पहले हम आते हैं यहां पे काली में एंड
यहां पे हम देखते हैं जब हमारा वन फॉर ऑल
पे चलते हैं इसके अंदर में इसमें अंदर में
रिपोर्ट्स नाम का एक डायरेक्टरी बना होगा
कहां गई रिपोर्ट वेज रिपोर्ट्स वन फॉर ऑल
का रिजल्ट्स रिजल्ट्स यहां बना है
रिजल्ट्स के अंदर चलते हैं एंड रिजल्ट्स
के अंदर यहां आपका जो
टेंपररी में चलते हैं अ ले ये रही
[संगीत]
अ
samsung.com इट फाउंड
2307 तो 2000 यहां से 2000 यहां से हम
इनको मिक्स कर देंगे ठीक है पहले तो अभी
आने देते हैं अभी तो बहुत सारे अभी आपके
बनेंगे अभी अभी भी ये काम कर रहा होगा
शायद 17 पर पे काम कर रहा है बट ठीक है
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हमारे पास सब डोमेंस आ
रहे हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है सब डोमेंस
आएंगे ठीक है तो ये आपको सब डोमेंस और ये
सबसे बड़ी बात है आपके लाइव सब डोमेंस
निकाल के यह देगा जो सब डोमेंस मोस्टली
वर्किंग है वही सब डोमेंस आपको निकाल केय
देता है ये इसकी खासियत है ये इसकी खूबी
है ठीक है सो लेट इट फाइंड द सब डोमेंस
ओके मतलब मैं सेफ हूं i7 है रम 32gb अरे
बहुत है यार बहुत बढ़िया बहुत अच्छी बात
है बहुत है बहुत
है ओवर क्लॉकिंग नहीं किया यह डिफॉल्ट
मेरा है प्रोसेसर का अच्छा मुझे ठीक
है अभी तो बहुत कुछ देखेंगे यार अभी तो 20
पर ही हुआ है ये इसको चलने देते हैं 20 पर
हुआ है इसको हम अभी रोक भी देंगे कोई बात
नहीं तो हमारे पास जितने सब डोमस है उतने
आ जाएंगे हमारे पास कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
उतने सब डोमस वी हैव गैदर्ड ऑलरेडी राइट
बट हमें क्योंकि थोड़ा ज्यादा चाहिए तो
इसलिए मैं थोड़ा वेट कर रहा हूं कि थोड़ा
ज्यादा हमारे पास सब डोमेंस आ जाता तो
बढ़िया रहा ता हालांकि हम ओपन फॉर ऑल में
यहां पे ऊपर में जाओगे तो यहां पे कुछ
हेल्प फाइल में आप जाओगे तो वहां पे थोड़ा
थ्रेडिंग का कांसेप्ट आएगा तो उसको आप कर
सकते हो थोड़ा फास्ट करने के लिए बट स्टिल
अभी के लिए ठीक है जितना चल रहा है 3464
में से 700 कुछ हुए हैं थोड़ा इसमें टाइम
लग जाएगा फिलहाल के लिए हमारे पास कुछ
रिजल्ट्स तो आ ही चुके हैं यहां पे
रिपोर्ट्स में रिजल्ट्स में चलेंगे तो एक
रिजल्ट यहां पे आपका आ चुका है
दो सबड मतलब हमारे पास क्या हो गए अब देखो
हमारे पास क्या हो
गए टेंप में चलते हैं यह रही ओके यह वाली
मिली आपके सब डोमस की लिस्ट यहां इसको ओपन
करते हैं यह सारे सब डोमस आपको मिल जाते
हैं ठीक है तो हम जैसा कि हम करते हैं
ऑलरेडी जैसा कि हम हमेशा से करते आ रहे
हैं वो काम करेंगे पहले लेकिन हम अब क्या
करेंगे एक चीज यूज करेंगे एंड वो है हमारा
ये
रही वो जो टूल है वो है हमारा शफल डीएनएस
ठीक है सफल डीएनएस सफल डीएनएस इज अ रैपर
अराउंड मास डीएनएस तो सफल डीएनएस को देखो
यहां पे कैसे इसको यूज करना है आपको ये भी
आपको यहां पे दिख जाएगा शफल डीएनएस हाइन
डी उसके बाद डोमेन का जो डोमेन है वो नाम
हाइन डब्लू वर्ड्स वर्डलिस्ट जो है वो और
रिजॉल्वर ये रिजॉल्वर आपके सामने आ जाएगा
अब इससे भी हम सब डोमेंस जो है वो ब्रूट
फोर्स करके हम सब डोमेंस को ब्रूट फोर्स
करके फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे
पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन के लिए ठीक है तो इसको
यूज कैसे करना है पहले मैं आपको बता देता
हूं सबसे पहले आपको मास डीएनएस चाहिए होगा
हो आपके सिस्टम पे क्या एप्ट इंस्टॉल मास
डीएनएस बिना इसके यह काम नहीं करेगा याद
रखिएगा ठीक है अब मैं सफल डीएनएस
को स्टार्ट करूंगा तो यह स्टार्ट हो जाएगा
एंड हाइन एच लगाइए तो इसकी हेल्प फाइल के
साथ ये स्टार्ट हो जाएगा ठीक है इस तरीके
से स्टार्ट हो जाएगा तो मास डीएनएस जरूर
इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा अदर वाइज ये काम नहीं
करेगा ओके अब कैसे यूज करना है आपको मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं
शफल एस एच य ड ए एल सफल डीएनएस कर दिया
हमने नडी
हम इससे भी निकालते हैं samsung.com
बढ़िया कहां गया
भाई ओके वेयर इट
गन आई डोंट नो कहां चला गया यह टैब ठीक है
यहां पे अब अगेन शफल डीएनएस को लंच करते
हैं शफल डीएनएस हाफ h एंड यहां पर करते
हैं हान डी
samsung.com के लिए samsung.com हमारा जो
टारगेट है उसके लिए h l से फाइल कंटेनिंग
लिस्ट ऑफ सब डोमस टू रिजॉल्व आपके पास
लिस्ट ऑफ सब डोमेंस है उनको रिजॉल्व करना
है तो आप ये काम कर सकते हैं हान डब् से
वर्ड लिस्ट आपको चाहिए होगा तो जो वर्ड
लिस्ट है ब्रूट फोर्स करने के लिए वो वर्ड
लिस्ट तो हम चलिए ब्रूट फोर्स करने के लिए
हमारे पास ऑलरेडी है हान w लगा देते हैं
हम एक दूसरी वर्ड लिस्ट यूज़ करने वाले
हैं हम सेम वर्ड लिस्ट यूज नहीं करने वाले
हैं ठीक है वर्डलिस्ट के लिए आप बढ़िया
वर्डलिस्ट कहां से निकाल सकते हैं मैं
आपको इसका ल दिखा देता हूं हमारे पास एक
एसेट नोट वर्डलिस्ट करके आता है एक लोकेशन
है एट नट ड वर्डलिस्ट यानी कि इसका जो
डोमेन है व
l.n. i ये वर्डलिस्ट है आपका यहां पे आप
आएंगे गाइस अ सो आपको यहां पे बहुत सारे
जो है ना व लिस्ट मिल जाएंगे साइज के साथ
आप यू कैन डाउनलोड इट तो मैं यहां पे
बेसिकली यहां से ओपन कर लेता हूं काली के
अंदर में ही थोड़ी बड़ी वर्ड लिस्ट है ये
बड़ी है तो इतना आप यूज करो ना करो आपकी
मर्जी है जब ये लोकल सिस्टम प आप यूज
करोगे गाइस तो इतना ह्यूज वर्डलिस्ट यूज
करोगे तो ज्यादा फायदा नहीं होगा जब आप
क्लाउड में यूज करोगे क्लाउड के सिस्टम प
आप ये वडस यूज करो बहुत फास्ट होगा तो
आपका यह सक्सेस भी होगा बट लोकल सिस्टम प
करोगे उतना करते करते ये बहुत टाइम ले
लेगा इतना याद रखना इतना रिसोर्स ही नहीं
होता है अच्छा आप लोगों में से कितने
लोग यह चाहते हैं कि मैं आपके लिए वीपीएस
या क्लाउड सेटअप कैसे करते हैं बग बाउंट
के लिए क्लाउड में बग बांटी का कैसे सेटअप
करना है मशीन कैसे कॉल करनी है कैसे क्या
सेटअप करना है अगर आपको इसका वीडियो चाहिए
तो मुझे बता दीजिए जल्दी से बता दीजिए
मुझे चैट में इफ यू वांट
टू
राइट लेट आए हो आपको मैं यू आर लेट आई
थिंक सो कांट रिपीट आप इसकी रिकॉर्डिंग
देखिएगा प्लीज ठीक है अगर आप चाहते हो तो
आई
विल ठीक है यहां पर बहुत सारे वर्ड लिस्ट
है आपको दिख आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे
यहां पे 12 टोटल पेजेस है यहां पे एंड
इनमें से आपको सारी वर्ड लिस्ट मिल जाएगी
यहां पे यह
देखिए यह देखिए यहां पे 2 मिलियन सब
डोमेंस ये देख रहे हो तुम 28 एमबी की
कितने कितने हैं
इसमें 21 लाख सब डोमेंस के लिए सब डोमस
जनरेटर है ये बिंग क्वेरी है 21 लाख ये
वाले और चलो नीचे आ जाओ ये डीएनएस वड
लिस्ट इसमें कितने 99 लाख बहुत ज्यादा
बड़ा है ये 139 एय बहुत बड़ा है इतना बड़ा
हम नहीं यूज करने वाले हम 2 मिलियन सबमनस
वाला है इसको यूज कर सकते हैं ल यूज दिस
राइट ओके डाउनलोड पर क्लिक कर लेते हैं
एंड लेट्स सी यहां पर आ चुका है हमारा ड
एक्सटी चलिए अच्छी बात है लेट्स ट्राई टू
गेट इट चलिए लेट्स ट्राई टू गेट इट डबल
गेट एंड देखते हैं डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं
इसको इस फाइल को 2 मिलियन सब 28 एबी के
आसपास की फाइल है तो जस्ट वेट एंड
च ओके सो वी गट दिस फाइल व लिस्ट यह कहां
गई कहां गई कहां गई कहां गई क गई गई गई क
गई यह रहा मिलियन समय वालपेपर थोड़ा सा
चेंज कर देता हूं एक्चुअली थोड़ा ज्यादा
क्लियर दिखता नहीं है इस वाले वॉलपेपर में
प्लेन वाली लगा देता हूं बाकी सारी फाइल्स
दिख जाएंगी राइट तो ये सारी फाइल्स आपको
दिख जाएंगी 2 मिलियन सब डोमस आ गई यहां पे
यहां पे इसके अंदर में पता नहीं कितने
सारे सब डोमेंस की ब्रूट फोर्सिंग की
लिस्ट है ये वॉर्ड लिस्ट है एंड इस वर्ड
लिस्ट को देखो क्या होता है जब तुम ये
वॉर्ड लिस्ट को यूज़ कर रहे हो ना तुम
ब्रूट फोर्स कर रहे हो अब ब्रूट फोर्स का
मतलब क्या है मैं आपको समझा देता हूं देखो
जैसे आप क्या कर रहे हो ना ब्रूट फोर्स कर
रहे हो ब्रूट फोर्स ब्रूट फोर्स कर रहे हो
सब डोमेन के लिए सब डोमस के लिए जब तुम
वर्डलिस्ट का यूज़ कर रहे हो वर्ड लिस्ट
अब जब तुम वर्डलिस्ट का यूज़ करके ब्रूट
फोर्स कर रहे हो ना तो क्या होगा तुम्हारी
आईपी से रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी अब एक वर्ड लिस्ट
उठाएगा और रिक्वेस्ट जाएगा दूसरा उठाएगा
रिक्वेस्ट जाएगा तीसरा उठाएगा रिक्वेस्ट
जाएगा अब सेम आईपी से अलग-अलग वर्ड लिस्ट
के रिक्वेस्ट जाएंगे किसी पर्टिकुलर सर्वर
पे तो वो सर्वर आपकी आईपी को ब्लॉक कर
देगा या आपकी आईपी को थोड़ी देर के लिए
टेंपररी बैन कर देगा या व्हाट एवर दे कैन
डू जो भी उनके फायर वल सिक्योरिटी जो भी
उनके सर्वर की सिक्योरिटी है उसके
अकॉर्डिंग होगा तो इस जगह पे हमें यहां पे
हम यहां पे क्या करते हैं रिजॉल्वर्स का
यूज कर लेते हैं रिजॉल्व करने के लिए मतलब
इससे फ हैं मल्टीपल बेनिफिट्स है आपके पास
रिजॉल्वर्स को यूज करने का तो हम
रिजॉल्वर्स में डिफरेंट डिफरेंट आईपीस को
यूज कर लेते हैं चलिए तो हम यहां पे क्या
करते हैं रिजॉल्वर्स की मेरे पास एक लिस्ट
है ये आईपीस एंड पोर्ट की यह देखिए हम
इसको यूज करेंगे अब सबसे बड़ी बात यह आपको
कहां से मिलेगा भैया तो बहुत आसान है यहां
पे सीधा जाइएगा रिजॉल्व t एकटी सर्च कर
लीजिएगा ऐसे बहुत सारे रिजॉल्वर्स मिल
जाएंगे तो आपको मास्क डीएनएस का रिजॉल्वर
जो फाइल है ये आपको यहां पर मिल जाएगा एंड
आप इसको डाउनलोड करके डायरेक्टली यूज कर
सकते हैं ये रिजॉल्वर फा t एकटी फाइल है
ठीक है चलिए एवरीवन गेटिंग अ रेडी हो सभी
लोग तो सफल डीएनएस को यूज करना है सफल
डीएनएस हान h कर देते हैं एंटर कर देते
हैं सफल डीएस के बाद h d लगा देते हैं
सॉरी एंड यहां पे हम अपना टारगेट डोमेन
samsung.com लगा देते हैं samsung.com
चलिए h d लगा दिया samsung.com उसके बाद
हान w से आपको वर्ड लिस्ट आपको बतानी है
कौन सी वर्ड लिस्ट यूज करने है तो नड एंड
वर्ड लिस्ट कौन सा था हमारा भैया 2 मिलियन
वाला वर्डलिस्ट था ये हमने वर्ड लिस्ट लगा
दिया चलिए ये बहुत बड़ी वर्ड लिस्ट है बीच
में हमें शायद रोकना पड़ जाएगा मे बी उसके
बाद रिजॉल्व लगाना है तो हान r लगा देते
हैं एंड रिजॉल्वर्स डट txt.gz
आउटपुट में देखो यहां पे आउटपुट रिजल्ट
देख सकते हैं यहां पे
अ यह वाला आप लगा सकते हैं ओनली सब डोमस
इन आउटपुट तो ओनली सब डोमेंस आपके आएंगे
आउटपुट में हान साइलेंट लगा देने से एंड
हान o से आप यहां पे आपके आउटपुट जो है एक
फाइल बन जाएगी उसमें चली जाएगी ठीक है
फिलहाल के लिए हम यहां पे लगा देते हैं
एंड यहां पे हमने हान o लगाया एंड हमने
क्या दे दिया
samsungfunclubs.com चलिए और इसमें हम हान
v भी लगा देते हैं ताकि हमें दिखता भी रहे
कि व्हाट इट इज डूइंग एक्चुअली तो ये
स्टार्ट हो रहा है देख सकते हैं आप यहां
पे देख सकते हैं परम्यूटेशन जनरेट कर रहा
है रूट फोर्स परम्यूटेशन जो होती है मास
डीएनएस का बाइनरी डिस्कवर हो गया नहीं
होता तो ये नहीं चलता मास डीएनएस का
टेंपररी आउटपुट फाइल बनाया और मास डीएनएस
को एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा है samsung.com पे
एंड उसके बाद आपको रिजल्ट देना ये शुरू
करेगा ठीक है सो वी हैव टू वेट
a.txt ये एक फाइल बननी चाहिए जिसके अंदर
आपके डोमस सब डोमस जो है वो होने चाहिए
ठीक है फिलहाल के लिए आपको वेट करना
पड़ेगा क्योंकि अ दिस विल टेक सम टाइम
काफी ह्यूज वर्ड लिस्ट है काफी बड़ी वर्ड
लिस्ट है तो थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा जब वर्ड
लिस्ट ऐसी ह्यूज वर्ड लिस्ट को आप क्लाउड
में यूज करोगे ना भैया तो मजा आ जाएगा
आपको क्लाउड में ठीक है तो मैं आपको जल्दी
ही क्लाउड में कैसे बग बांटी का पूरा लैब
सेटअप या बग
बाउंट करते हो ताकि स्पीड वो मेंटेन हो
जाए और मैं आपको कुछ रिकमेंडेशंस भी बता
दूंगा चीप अल्टरनेट बता दूंगा क्योंकि देख
एडब्ल्यू वगैरह यूज
करोगे
google2 हो रहा है यहां पे एंड ये चल रहा
है
जो भी आउटपुट होंगी वो
ओके लेट इट
शो थोड़ा सा टाइम लग रहा है तो क्योंकि
वर्डलिस्ट कुछ ज्यादा ही बड़ी है अपनी ट्स
वाई
लेट्स
वेट अटिल देन टेक द डाउट्स क्या डाउट्स है
भाई बताइए बिल्कुल
अ लेट्स
सी क्वेश्चन है सर आपके अंदर इतना
कॉन्फिडेंस कैसे है इतने सारे लोग आपको
लाइव देख रहे हैं बट कोई नर्वसनेस नहीं है
कोई हेजिन नहीं है लो हाउ प्लीज शेयर योर
सीक्रेट इसमें नर्वसनेस वाली कोई बात नहीं
है यार लोग देख रहे हैं तो और मेरे अंदर
इसलिए भी नहीं है क्योंकि मैं काफी टाइम
से अ कंटेंट क्रिएशन में हूं काफी टाइम से
ये सब चीजें कर रहा हूं तो मुझे आदत हो गई
है बाकी जो लोग नए आ रहे हैं जो लोग
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं उनको थोड़ा होता है पर
धीरे-धीरे धीरे-धीरे वो यूज टू आप हो
जाएंगे इसके राइट कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है
ओके इट विल टेक टाइम बिकॉज़ यह सब ये बहुत
बड़ी वो फाइल है आपको मैं यहां पे लाइव
दिखा देता हूं मैं आउटपुट वाली फाइल
फिलहाल हटा देता हूं ताकि यह आपको सामने
दिख जाए जो भी हो रहा है आपको सामने दिखे
जरा तो मैं आउटपुट वाली फाइल हटा देता हूं
ठीक है नवी लगा के डायरेक्ट वर्वस आउटपुट
हम डायरेक्ट देखेंगे यहां पे सामने हमें
दिखना चाहिए अब जो भी आपने आपके जो भी
डिस्कवर हो रहा है वो सामने हमें दिख जाना
चाहिए सो लेट्स
वेट samsung.com नड हमने लगा दिया 2
मिलियन सबड एकटी हमने लगा दिए हैं बढ़िया
रिजॉल्वर हमने सेट कर दिया है एंड ट्स इट
ठीक
है
ट्स इट हो गया
बढ़िया चलिए देखते चलते हैं थोड़ा वेट
करते हैं अदर वाइज हम थोड़ा छोटा लिस्ट ले
लेंगे बट स्टिल इट शुड बी शोइंग द
रिजल्ट्स
ओके इट शुड बी शोइंग द रिजल्ट्स राइट
नाउ शुड बी अभी तक कुछ हमें रिजल्ट्स आए
नहीं है कुछ मिल नहीं रहा हमें रिजल्ट में
ऐसा क्यों हो रहा है टू
चेक लेट्स चेक लेट्स चेक एक काम करते हैं
यह वाली जो हमारी वड लिस्ट है इसको हटा
देते हैं एंड हमारी छोटी वाली वर्डलिस्ट
जो है ना उसको यूज कर लेते हैं
ए जीरो वाली एंड देन हम देखते
हैं कि रिजल्ट हमें थोड़ा फास्ट मिलता है
कि नहीं मिलता है लेट
सी
ओ एक हम डोमेन चेंज करते हैं लेट्स चेक द
डोमेन
लेट्स चेक द डोमेन डोमेन हम चेंज करते हैं
डोमेन हम देते हैं लेंस कॉ आई थिंक मे बी
डोमेन का इशू कुछ हो कुछ ऐसा हो कुछ हो
अभी बट एक बार डोमेन चेंज करके देख लेते
हैं न car.com
नथिंग
नथिंग ओके देयर इज सम इश्यूज कुछ इश्यूज
है अभी करेंटली तभी यह कुछ आउटपुट हमें दे
नहीं रहा है देर शुड बी सम इश्यूज कुछ ना
कुछ तो होना चाहिए देन ट्स वई वी आर नॉट
गेटिंग एनी रिजल्ट्स राइट कोई रिजल्ट हमें
मिल नहीं रहा है फिलहाल कुछ भी रिजल्ट
नहीं आ रहा तो कुछ ना कुछ प्रॉब्लम है
चलिए एक बार बाकी हमने सब कुछ फ्लैग सही
दिए हैं वर्ड लिस्ट हमने मेंटेन कर दिया
है वर्डलिस्ट मेंशन कर दिया है रिजॉल्वर
हमने दे दिया
है
ओके अपडेटेड वर्जन है हमारा एक बार अपडेट
चेक कर लेते हैं शफल डीएनएस हाइन
अपडेट लेट्स सी कुछ अपडेट है क्या ऑलरेडी
टू द न्यूस्ट वर्जन है यहां पे बाकी सारी
चीजें वी आर गिविंग एब्सलूट फाइन एक नवी
हटा देते हैं एक बार हटा के देखते एक बार
क्या होता है लेट्स रिमूव नवी एंड लेट्स
एक्सक्यूट
इट
ओके नथिंग
नथिंग रिजॉल्वर कोई और यूज करें कहने का
मतलब यह है क्या टू यूज सम अदर रिजॉल्वर्स
ओके एक काम करते हैं लेट्स चेंज द
रिजॉल्वर फाइल रिजॉल्वर में से कुछ आईपीस
को हटा देते हैं यहां से लेट्स रिमूव सम
आईपीस
अ ओके कुछ आईपीस हटा देते हैं शायद मे भी
कुछ रिजॉल्वर हमारे काम ना कर रहे हो ऐसा
भी हो सकता है एंड फिर अब चेक आउट करते
हैं एंड दूसरा हम रिजॉल्वर भी ले लेते एक
बार एक बार डीएनएस डीएनएस
रिजॉल्वर एक बार सर्च कर लेते
हैं इ आवर इंटरनेट वर्किंग क्या बात
है यह क्यों नहीं काम कर रहा है हमारा
इंटरनेट नहीं काम कर रहा है क्या
ओके तो वही मैं बोल रहा हूं यार कि काम
क्यों नहीं रहा हमारा इंटरनेट नहीं काम कर
रहा क्या पिन करते हैं
google.com यप काम नहीं कर रहा भाई तभी तो
ये ये नहीं काम कर रहा है हटो यार हटो हटो
हटो चलो
पिंग google.com ये सिली चीजें होती है
अभी तो पिंग हो रही है बढ़िया अभी तो पिंग
हो रहा है यह भी ओपन हो
चुका ठीक है यहां से कुछ रिजॉल्वर्स उठा
लेते हैं सेक लिस्ट से हमने रिजॉल्वर आई
थिंक ये उठाए थे क्या नहीं ये दूसरा
रिजॉल्वर लिस्ट है ये शायद हां वो मास
डीएनएस का ये सेक लिस्ट का रिजॉल्वर है हम
इसको भी उठा लेते हैं डेनेस रिजॉल्वर्स
इसको उठा लेते हैं एंड इसको हम डेस्कटॉप
पे ला देते हैं ठीक है सो लेट्स पुट दिस
ऑन डेस्कटॉप डीस रिजॉल्वर नाम से एंड अब
देखते हैं एक बार उस टाइम शायद शायद
इंटरनेट का इशू होगा पता नहीं आई डोंट नो
बट लेट्स ट्राई विद द सेम लेंस कार्ट एंड
सेम
रिजॉल्वर अ देखते हैं क्योंकि रिजल्ट आपको
यह बहुत जल्दी देता है रिजल्ट में ज्यादा
टाइम नहीं लगेगा क्योंकि मास डीएनएस यूज
हो र है ये मास डीएनएस जो है यूज हो रहा
है बैकग्राउंड में
आपके
[संगीत]
अ ओके समझ गया यह इसका इशू है रिजॉल्वर का
इशू लग रहा है मुझे क्लियर तो वी आर गोइंग
टू चेंज द रिजॉल्वर फाइल एंड यहां पे हम
रिजॉल्वर t एक्टी जो है इसको हम कर देते
हैं चेंज करके डीएनए रिजॉल्वर टीटी एंड
नाउ लेट्स सी हमने रिजॉल्वर्स चेंज किए
हैं डीस रिजॉल्वर्स एंड अब देखते हैं कि
यह कुछ कर पाता है या नहीं कर पाता है
लेट्स
ट्रा नथिंग
नथिंग रिजॉल्वर्स का रिजॉल्व करने के लिए
होता है बस और कुछ नहीं रिजॉल्व करते हैं
और कुछ भी नहीं ठीक है जैसे रिजॉल्व
डीएनएस का काम क्या है बताइए आप लोगों को
नहीं पता क्या डीएनएस का काम क्या है
रिजॉल्व करना बस वही रिजॉल्व करता है
डोमेन टू
आईपी
ठीक
है सो दिस वन इज आल्सो नॉट वर्किंग आई
थिंक लेट्स ट्राई टू फाइंड सम इधर सम
डिफरेंट रिजॉल्वर कुछ और रिजॉल्वर लेके
चलते हैं एक बार बिकॉज यह रिजॉल्वर का ही
इशू लग रहा है मुझे यहां पर अगर हम
रिजॉल्वर ना दे तो डिफॉल्ट यूज करेगा नो
रिजॉल्वर लिस्ट प्रोवाइडेड ला राइट तो
डिफॉल्ट का कुछ सीन है नहीं यहां पे एक
रिजवर ऑलरेडी अवेलेबल है तो एक बार डीएनएस
वैलिडेटर से यूज हुआ है
यह रिजॉल्वर ट्रस्टेड दो सब दो वीक पहले
हुआ है यह रिजॉल्वर व 15 आवर्स अगो
रिजॉल्वर जो है यह हुआ है अपडेट तो यह ले
लेते हैं एक बार रिजॉल्व एक्टी ठीक है एंड
इसको मैं रिनेम कर देता हूं रिजॉल्वर
रिजॉल्वर
फाइनल एक्टी कर देता हूं मैं एंड इसको हम
डेस्कटॉप प रख देते हैं फिलहाल के लिए
राइट रिजॉल्व फाइनल नाम से हमने कर दिया
एंड हम अब इसी को यूज करने वाले हैं सेम
कमांड में लेट्स सी
रिजॉल्वर रिजॉल्वर फाइनल्स
लेट्स
सी क्योंकि अपडेटेड रिजॉल्वर है तो देखते
हैं काम करता है कि नहीं करता है शफल डीस
लेंस काड प हम कर रहे हैं आड एंड हमने यह
वाली चूज कर ली है सब डोमस की लिस्ट वड
लिस्ट एंड नाउ वी आर
ट्रांग
ओके
नथिंग कुछ भी नहीं हो पा रहा है
राइट क्या इशू होना क्या इशू होगा आप आप
लोग बताइए कुछ क्या इशू हो सकता है आप लोग
बताइए
कुछ रिजॉल्व हटा के नहीं होगा
बताइए क्या इशू हो सकता
है व्ट इशू कैन इट
बी टूक टूक टक टूक टक
टूक टेल मी इसको
हम
दे
नथिंग रंग यर आप आपको क्या लग रहा है
बताइए कुछ रंग यहां पर है नहीं हम कुछ
कमांड में गलती नहीं कर रहे यह बात एकदम
से ध्यान रखिएगा व आर नॉट मेकिंग एनी
मिस्टेक इन कमांड सो व्ट इशू इट माइट बी
चलिए इस इशू को एक बार एक बार एक काम करते
हैं इसके इश्यूज में देख लेते हैं क्या
इशू है मशीन प्ली चेक
ल् रीइंस्टॉल करके देखो इंस्टॉल हाई
ट्रैफिक टूल रिक्वायरमेंट और डिपेंडेंसी
नहीं यार टूल रिक्वायरमेंट हो ऐसी होती तो
चलता ही नहीं ना एक काम करते हैं वी आर
डूइंग थिंग हम एक काम करते
हैं क्या काम करते हैं मैं बता देता हूं
मैं क्या काम करता हूं इसका एक तरीका
देखता हूं मैं इसको रीबूट कर देता हूं
मशीन को एक बार लेट्स रीबूट दिस मशीन ठीक
है इस मशीन को रिबूट कर देते हैं
एंड लेट्स फ्लस द
डीएनएस
लेट्स फ्लश डीएनएस एंड रिबूट दिस
मशीन रिबूट दिस मशीन एंड नाउ लेट्स
ट्राई
ओके ओके लेट्स ट्राई
बिना ट्राई किए तो कैसे रह सकते हैं भैया
करेक्ट
चलिए तो यह हमने ओपन कर लिया एंड नाउ
लेट्स
ट्राई हम रिजॉल्वर फाइनल ड इसी पर ट्राई
कर लेते हैं
एंड बताता हूं क्या होगा इस टूल से अभी
आपको पता चल
जाएगा अगेन लेट्स
वेट ओके दिस गेटिंग ब्लॉकड बलक रही
य एक काम करते हैं ना पब्लिक डीएनएस ले
लेते हैं एक काम करते हैं पब्लिक डीएनएस
रिजॉल्वर्स को यूज करते हैं लेट्स ट्राई
फॉर पब्लिक डीएनएस रिजॉल्वर्स ठीक है तो
लेट्स गो फॉर पब्लिक डीएनएस रिजॉल्वर एंड
देन देखते हैं ट्राई करके कि यह काम करता
है कि नहीं करता है हालांकि कुछ कुछ तो हम
वैसे भी डाल देंगे लेकिन ठीक है फिर भी
स्टिल व आर
सी पब्लिक डीएनएस
[संगीत]
रिजॉल्व इसको क्लोज करना इसको बंद करना
पड़ेगा तभी ये चालू होगा आपका ठीक है
लिस्ट नहीं है क्या टी एक्सटी टी एक्सटी
नहीं मिलेगी क्या इसकी
फाइल यह तो हमने देख लिया यह हमने देख
लिया एक काम करते हैं हमने एक सिंपल सा
डीएनएस जो हमारा रिजॉल्वर है ना रिजॉल्व क
गई ल् ये रिजॉल्व इसमें बहुत सारे रिजॉल्व
है ऑलरेडी हम क्या करते हैं यहां पर एक
रिजॉल्वर का बना लेते
हैं
पब्लिक
रिजॉल्वर t एकटी ठीक है पब्लिक रिजॉल्वर t
एकटी इसमें ज्यादा नहीं कुछ करते हैं
1.11.1 कर देते हैं
8.8.8 कर देते हैं
8.8.8 4.4 कर देते हैं ये तीन ही रखते हैं
फिलहाल के लिए राइट जो हमारा पब्लिक
डीएनएस यूज हो रहा
है डबल क ठीक है अब इसको पास करके देखते
हैं यहां पे पब्लिक डीएनएस को कि यह क्या
करता है लाइक व्हाट इट्स डूइंग
नथिंग ओके हमने आईपी तो हमने तो वो दिया
ही नहीं यार सॉरी हमने तो सिर्फ डीएनएस का
वो डाल दिया डीएनएस डाल दिया हमने
रिजॉल्वर के लिए आईपी पोर्ट हमने जो देना
था वो तो दिया ही नहीं है तो ये गलती कर
दी हमने इसके लिए एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी हमें
ये हमारा वैसे भी काम नहीं करेगा हमने
डीएनएस मेंशन किया हमने रिजॉल्व के लिए
पोर्ट पोर्ट
का वो 80 का यहां पे बहुत सारे है तो
सही डीस हमने पब्लिक ओनली पब्लिक का ट्राई
करते हैं यार एक बार लेट्स
ट्राई लेट्स ट्राई एक बार विम के
साथ पब्लिक रिजॉल्वर तैयार कर लेते हैं एक
बार एंड इस बार इसमें ना सिर्फ डालते हैं
1.11.1 एंड 8 1.1.11 करते हैं ओनली सिर्फ
ये करते हैं ठीक
है आई थिंक हो गया लेट्स ट्राई नाउ एंड
लेट्स सी क्या होता
है देखते
हैं इफ एनी डिफरेंसेस इट्स मेकिंग कुछ हो
नहीं रहा है तो एक काम करते हैं शफल
डीएनएस प चलते हैं इनके रिपोजिटरी पे
देखते हैं यहां पे कुछ ऐसा कुछ इशू आ रहे
हैं क्या इनका इनका कुछ नॉर्मल इशू है
क्या इनका शफल डीएनएस का चलिए
[संगीत]
नथिंग यहां
पे क्लोज इशू है यहां पे ओके राउटर राउटर
क्रशिंग हां राउटर क्रशिंग यह इशू है
क्योंकि इंटरनेट काम नहीं कर
रहा हे मा राउटर गेट क्रश टेंपररी वाइल
यूजिंग शफल डीएनएस कैन यू लेट फिक्स ठीक
है गो टू डिस्कशन
यहां डिस्कशन में आ जाते हैं क्या है भाई
शफल डी यूज मास डीन व्हिच इज नेटवर्क
इंटेंसिव एंड कैन मेक डाउन लो फास्ट आइडल
यू शुड नॉट बी रनिंग दिस स्कैन ऑन द लोकल
नेटवर्क इंस्टेड यूज क्लाउड वीपीएस वही
बात है इन्होंने भी वही चीज मेंशन करी है
आप देख सकते हैं कि ये लोकल नेटवर्क पे
बोल रहा है कि आपको
रिकमेंडेबल उड मशीन पे कोई यूज करो तब
जाके सही रहेगा आपका शायद चल जाए बढ़िया
से चल जाए अदर वाइज फिर बहुत मुश्किल होगी
क्योंकि यह बहुत ही ज्यादा नेटवर्क
इंटेंसिव टूल है बस यह चीज इन्होंने बता
रखा है तो यहां से आपको एक चीज पता चल गई
होगी यह चीज आपको समझ में आ गया होगा राइट
ये और कोई इसका इशू नहीं है और कोई इसकी
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है बस यही प्रॉब्लम है कि
भैया यह बहुत ही नेटवर्क इंटेंसिव है
इसलिए दिक्कत दे रही है बस और कुछ नहीं
यहां पे राउटर क्रशिंग आ गई अल्टरनेटिव
टूडी ठीक है और कुछ तो है नहीं ऐसा कुछ डज
नॉट डू एनीथिंग
[संगीत]
अ नथिंग नथिंग कुछ भी नहीं
है
हा टेस्टेड रिजॉल्वर्स को यूज कर रहे हैं
ये ठीक है टेस्टेड रिजॉल्वर्स देख लेते
हैं टेस्टेड रिजॉल्वर्स टी एक्सटी कुछ अगर
मिल जाता है हमें तो ट्रस्टेड वाली मिली
हमें यह ठीक है ट्रस्टेड वाली है यह तो यह
सेम ही है शायद य है ना
हां रिजॉल्वर ट्रस्टेड जो है यह हमने
डाउनलोड करके रखी है क्या रिजॉल्वर्स
ट्रस्टेड वाली जो है एक बार देख लेते हैं
ट्रस्टेड रिजॉल्वर्स
आई डोंट थिंक सो कि हमने हमारे पास ट्रस्ट
रिजॉल्व वाली लिस्ट
है लेट्स क्लोज इट एंड लेट्स चेक ट्रस्टेड
रिजॉल्वर वाली है यहां पे नहीं है राइट सो
लेट्स डाउनलोड
इट ट्रस्टेड रिजॉल्वर वाली एक बार डाउनलोड
कर लेते हैं एंड देन हम इसको देखते हैं
ठीक
है रिजॉल्वर इशू एंड मशीन का इशू है
क्लाउड में आप कर सकते हैं क्लाउड में यह
बिल्कुल काम करेगा उसके लिए आपको टेंशन
नहीं लेनी है ठीक है रिजॉल्व ट्रस्टेड
वाली है क्लाउड में य 110 पर आपकी काम
करेगी रिजॉल्वर ट्रस्टेड आ गई अब इसको एक
बार चला के देख लेते हैं ठीक है इसके बाद
भी काम नहीं करेगा तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं आप
क्लाउड में कीजिएगा हो जाएगा ये बाकी सारे
स्टेप्स आप आपके बिल्कुल ही परफेक्ट है
रिजॉल्वर्स ट्रस्टेड कोई गलती नहीं यहां
पे एंड यहां पे हमने
ठीक
है ओके चलिए तो इसको अभी फिलहाल के लिए
रहने देते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में जब हम
देखेंगे क्लाउड वगैरह सेटअप करेंगे आपको
भी मैं ताकि वह चीज सेम सेटअप करूंगा आपको
सेम बताता चलूंगा तो आपको वहां पे यह चीज
हम ये टूल देखेंगे क्लाउड में चला के एंड
उस टाइम में देखेंगे हमारा बिल्कुल
परफेक्ट चल रहा होगा ठीक है राइट तो चलिए
अब हमारे पास क्या है मैं पहले आपको ये
चीज दिखा देता हूं समझा देता हूं हमारे
पास
देते हैं टप में
[संगीत]
samsung.com की संख्या
4493 है अब इसको हम शॉटिंग करेंगे शॉर्ट
करेंगे शॉर्ट करेंगे कैसे श
गया
भैया क्या हुआ भाई कहां ये गई कहां
पे अच्छा अच्छा अा ओके ओके कैट
samsung.com आ गए मान लो हमारे पास ठीक है
चलेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं अब हम इसमें क्या
करेंगे हम इसपे एसटीटीपी एकस चला देंगे
एटीटीपी एक् चलाएंगे
हम एटीटीपी सर्वर्स को लाइक देख लेंगे कि
कौन से भाई एटीटीपी सर्वर किस पर काम कर
रहा है किस पर नहीं काम कर रहा है तो एक
तरह से लाइव प्रोब हम कर लेंगे ठीक है तो
प्रोब करने के लिए हमारे पास एडीपी एकस
टूल किट है आप सबको पता होना चाहिए और
सिंपल सा तरीका है तो क्या करेंगे भैया
कैट बहुत सिंपल है कैट
टूल किट ये यूज कर लेंगे एंड ऐसे करके
samsung.com एटीटीपी एक और एटीटीपी टूल
किट नॉट वर्किंग फॉर मी एनी अदर बेटर
अल्टरनेटिव भाविन यू कैन गो विद द एचटीटी
प्रोब जिनका एचटीटी पी एक का इशू है अगर
दिक्कत आ रही है तो आप टॉम नॉम नॉम भाई की
हमारी दूसरी जो है यूज कर लो एचटीटी प्रोब
टॉम नॉम नोम भाई की है क्या ये शायद
उन्हीं की है हां उन्हीं की है ये
एचटी एचटीटी प्रोब आप इसको यूज कर सकते हो
सेम काम आपका करेगा आपका वेब सर्वर फिंगर
प्रिंटिंग करेगा ठीक है बस चलिए यह यहां
पे हो रहा है
शायद ज्यादा डोमस है तो थोड़ा टाइम लग रहा
है
इसके अंदर एंट्रीज हो रही होंगी मेरे
ख्याल से जहां तक मुझे लग रहा है
[संगीत]
आपको थोड़ा स्पीड इशू आएगा थोड़ी सी
स्लोने आएगी उसमें आप कुछ नहीं कर सकते वो
आपको झेलना पड़ेगा भाई ठीक है चलिए तो
लेट्स वेट इट टू कंप्लीट मैं तब तक एक
शेड्यूलिंग कर देता हूं इसको कंप्लीट होने
देते
हैं थोड़ा वेट कीजिए दो मिनट में हो जाएगा
य ज्यादा टाइम नहीं लगेगा क्योंकि थोड़ी
सी डोमेन ज्यादा है सब डोमेन हमारे पास
ज्यादा है इसलिए थोड़ा सा टाइम लग रहा है
और कुछ नहीं है राट
ओके सो लेट्स वेट फॉर इट टू
[संगीत]
कंप्लीट ठीक है तो वेट करते
हैं लेट मी शेड्यूल
मजा तो आही रहा होगा ट्राई करें क्या एमस
यूज कर सकते हो कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं एमस भी यूज कर लो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
एमस का थोड़ा आजकल प्रॉब्लम चल रहा है ट्स
वाई बाकी आप एमस यूज कर सकते हो कोई
प्रॉब्लम मैं य पर एक चीज कर रहा हूं जस्ट
जस्ट वेट लेट मी डू
समथिंग डूंग सम शेड्यूलिंग वर्क
ट डेट इ 8 जन 8 जन
राइट
ओके मैं एक चीज एक क्लास शेड्यूल कर रहा
हूं आप लोग तब तक रिजल्ट का वेट कीजिए
थोड़ा देर थोड़ी देर वेट कीजिए हो जाएगा
ये ठीक है सबो टेक भी आएंगे टेंशन मत लो
वो भी आएंगे आराम आराम से चलते चलो सब
आएगा सब आएगा ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेनी है
भैया ज्यादा टेंशन लोगे तो दिक्कत
है ठीक है ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेना है ठीक
है सभी आप सब डोमन टेकओवर सब कुछ सब कुछ
आएगा जो आप सोच रहे हो ठीक
है
ज्यादा ही सब डोमेन आ गए लग रहा
है हम चलिए हो गया यह यह काम हो गया चलिए
बढ़िया हमारा शेड्यूलिंग भी हो गया और इधर
भी हो गया यह अच्छी बात हो गई चलिए तो
हमने यह चीज़ अ यह हमारे रिजल्ट्स आ गए
हैं अब हम यहां पे एलएस करेंगे गाइ एंड वी
विल सी अ वी हैव द फाइल
[संगीत]
हा डब्लू स हान एल एंटर 672 हमारे पास जो
रिजॉल्व होके आया हैं हमारे पास जो प्रोब
होके आया हैं 672 सब डोमेंस नाउ वी हैव द
फाइनल सब डोमेंस वी हैव इन द लिस्ट फाइनल
सब डोमेंस हमारे पास है 672 अब हम 672 सब
डोमेंस की क्या करने वाले हैं हम इस पे हम
स्क्रीनशॉट करेंगे एंड डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्स करेंगे पहली बात तो यह है
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग के लिए हम क्या यूज़ करेंगे
आई विटनेस का यूज़ करेंगे बट उसके पहले
मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है बहुत जरूरी चीज है
आपको मैंने आज क्या बताया मैंने आपको जो
आज टूल सेट्स बताए क्या बताए आपको मैं
मैंने आपको बताया कि आप किसका यूज कर सकते
हो एक तो सब फाइंडर का यूज
करोगे यू विल इज य यू विल यूज सब फाइंडर
उसके बाद आप एफएफ यूएफ का यूज करोगे फिर
आप शफल डीएनएस का यूज करोगे अ वन फॉर ऑल
वन फॉर ऑल का यूज करोगे फिर आप शफल डीएनएस
का यूज करोगे ठीक है इसको आप मेनली वीपीएस
में यूज करोगे ज्यादा बढ़िया रहेगा बाकी
लोकल में ट्राई करना चला के चल जाए तो
बहुत अच्छी बात है ट्राई करना अगर आपका चल
भी सकता है कोई ठीक नहीं है ठीक है देन यू
विल गो फॉर व्हाट स्क्रीनशॉटिंग
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग इसके लिए हम आई विटनेस जो
हमारा टूल है सबसे बढ़िया ये यूज करेंगे
एंड देन हम करेंगे
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स जो कि बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है जो हम अभी करने वाले
हैं वीविल डू अभी करेंटली बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है बहुत मजा आएगा आपको
ठीक है तो ये चीज करेंगे चलिए तो अब हम
यहां पे आ जाते हैं यहां पे कुछ लोग
बेचारे बोर हो जाते हैं बट ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं वैसे लोगों के लिए क्लास है भी नहीं
जो लोग बोर हो जा रहे हैं उनके लोग उनके
लिए क्लास मैं वैसे भी नहीं लगाता जिनको
सीखना है ना जिनको बग
बाउंटीज जिनके अंदर एक स्पिरिट है वो
स्पिरिट मतलब कि बन के रहेंगे भाई प्रो
बनना है वही बस रहो बाकी टेंशन नहीं है
बाकी मैं हूं आपके लिए बना के रहूंगा यार
चाहे कुछ भी हो जाए उससे फर्क नहीं पड़ता
है आप बोर भी हो कोई बात नहीं मैं नहीं
होता बोर ओके 672 अ सब डोमेन यहां पे
हमारे पास आ चुके हैं हम पहले
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग कर लेते हैं जल्दी से कर
लेते हैं ठीक है तो क्या करेंगे भाई क्या
आई विटनेस करेंगे आई विटनेस i h हो गया
चलिए
अ आई विटनेस हमने लगा दिया अब हम यहां
पे वेब स्क्रीनशॉट ले लेंगे कोई बात नहीं
वेब स्क्रीनशॉट ले लेंगे तो हाई फन आई
विटनेस हाई फन हाई फन वेब लगा देते हैं
पहले देन अ वी विल गो विद
द फाइल न f दे देते हैं एंड हमारा फाइल
क्या है
[संगीत]
एटीटीपी एंड एटी टू ल विदाउट आदर अगर कोई
ऐसा यूआरएल का लिस्ट है आपके पास मान लो
आपके पास एक लिस्ट आ यूआरएल की जिसमें
एटीटीपी एचटीटीपीएस नहीं लगा है तो आप ये
ऑप्शन लगा सकते हो हाफ आफ प्री पेंड
एचटीटीपीएस तो ये सारे यल्स के पीछे
एटीटीपी एचटीटीपीएस लगा देगा तो उसके बाद
आपकी टेंशन खत्म हो जाएगी समझ में आ गया
सबको एवरीवन गॉट समझ में आ रहा है भाई बता
दीजिए मुझे सभी
लोग ठीक है चलिए उसके बाद यहां पे एक और
आपके स्विच है देखो
अ स्विच देखते
हैं कहां कहां गया कहां
गया ये थ्रेड थ्रेड आप लगा सकते हो नंबर
ऑफ थ्रेड्स टू यूज तो थोड़ी सी फास्ट करने
के लिए अगर आपको थ्रेडिंग करनी है थ्रेड
लगा के आप थोड़ी सी इसको फास्ट कर सकते हो
अगर आप चाहो तो ठीक है उसके बाद रिजल्ट के
लिए ये है नहीं चाहिए हमें भैया हमें ये
डिफॉल्ट दे
देगा
अ ऐड एसटीडीपी पोर्ट ये सब की जरूरत नहीं
है रिज्यूम में ठीक है बस
दैट्ची कोई दिक्कत नहीं है काम चल जाएगा
हमारा थ्रेड लगा देंगे तो बाकी थोड़ी सी
स्लो होगी बट थोड़ा फास्ट हो जाएगा उसके
बाद ठीक है तो चलिए हम इसमें थ्रेडिंग
थोड़ा सा लगा ही देते हैं
अ ये रही हाइन एफन थ्रेड्स ठीक है तो हान
थ्रेड लेते हैं टाइम आउट ये देखो डिफॉल्ट
टाइम आउट जो है ना सेवन सेकंड का है भैया
ये सेकंड्स सेवन सेकंड्स ओनली इसको हम
बढ़ा देते हैं पहले तो हाइ फन हाइ फन टाइम
आउट को हम सेवन से कर देते हैं 30 सेकंड
के लिए या 60 सेकंड के लिए कर देते हैं
यार या चलो 30 सेकंड के लिए कर देते हैं
30 सेकंड में हो जाता है काम ठीक है 30
सेकंड बहुत ज्यादा होते हैं हाइन हान टाम
हमने 30 सेकंड लगा दिया एंड हाइन थ्रेड
लगा देते हैं इसमें थोड़ा फास्ट करने के
लिए तो क्या लगाएंगे हाई फन एफन थ्रेड्स
नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड्स अ ठीक है तो हाई फन हान 3
ए आर ए डी एस थ्रेड लगा दिया हमने थ्रेड्स
लगा दिया हम 100 का कर देते हैं यार 100
100 कर देते हैं थ्रेड्स को ठीक है काफी
है इतना कर देते हैं और एंटर कर देते हैं
नाउ लेट्स वेट फॉर द रिजल्ट 662 होस्ट को
ये कर रहा है स्क्रीनशॉट ले रहा है
अटेंप्ट कर रहा है थ्रेड को हमने थोड़ा
बढ़ाया है तो थोड़ा सा फास्ट यहां पे आपको
आउटपुट देखने को मिल जाएगा थोड़ा थ्रेडिंग
आप और भी बढ़ा सकते हो इफ यू वांट यू कैन
जस्ट इंक्रीज द थ्रेड बट ये ठीक है ये
स्पीड ऑलमोस्ट ठीक है 100 वाला ज्यादा
करोगे तो थोड़ा फाल्स रिजल्ट कई सारे
स्किप भी कर देगा आपके मे बी तो ये आपकी
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग होनी जो है स्टार्ट हो चुकी
है अगर आप देखेंगे तो इसकी डायरेक्टरी बन
गई होगी यहां पे ये डेट वाइज डेस्कटॉप पे
आपके आ गई है एंड इसको ओपन करोगे तो आपको
स्क्रीनशॉट में आओगे तो यहां पे ये
स्क्रीनशॉट्स लेना इसने शुरू कर दिया है
जो भी सब डोमस है उसकी ठीक है चलिए ये तो
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग हो रही है स्क्रीनशॉटिंग हम
करेंगे इसके अलावा अब आपकी बारी आती है
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
सब डोमेंस कैसे फाइंड करना है तो यहां
पे एक टास्क आपको मैं दे देता हूं टास्क
में क्या
है ट्राई टू फाइंड सब
डोमस ऑफ सब डोमस ठीक है यहां पे एज मेनी
यू
कैन जितने आप चाहते हो उतने आपको ट्राई
करना है सब डोमस को फाइंड करने का यह मेन
मोटिव यही होना चाहिए आपका ठीक है उसके
बाद फरदर जो आगे के प्रोसेसेस है वो आपको
करने हैं राइट चलिए
तो हमारा काम काम यहां पे चल रहा है श
स्क्रीनशॉट का कितने स्क्रीनशॉट्स आ गए
लेट्स
सी बहुत सारे आ गए होंगे देखो बहुत सारे
स्क्रीनशॉट्स आ रहे हैं यार इतने सारे आ
गए 52 स्क्रीनशॉट्स तो अभी आ गए यहां पे
ठीक है तो चलो ये स्क्रीनशॉट्स तो यहां पे
आ रहे हैं इसके अब जब स्क्रीनशॉट आ जाएंगे
तो हमें डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स करनी है
फिलहाल के लिए तो फिलहाल के लिए अभी तो
स्क्रीनशॉट्स को हम देखना शुरू कर सकते
हैं इफ यू वांट यू कैन सी स्क्रीनशॉट्स को
देखना अदर वाइज आप थोड़ा वेट कर लो पूरी
स्क्रीनशॉटिंग हो जाने दो वीपीएस में क्या
है खासियत क्या है ना वीपीएस की भाई कि ये
जो तुम्हारा काम हो बहुत फास्ट होगा बहुत
फास्ट होगा तो वीपीएस की अगर तुम्हारे पास
है लाइक अफोर्ड कर सकते हो अफॉर्डेबिलिटी
है उतनी तो वीपीएस लेना बनता है यह देखो
आई सर्वर विंडो सर्वर रन हो रही है पेज
एरर कुछ पेज एरर आ रही है यह क्या पेजर
यार द यूआरएल इज नॉट अलाउड क्या बात है
नॉट
अलाउड यह क्या है
404 बैक एंड नॉट फाउंड सर्विस रूल्स फॉर द
पाथ नॉट एजिस्ट अब ये सब डोम टेक ओवर के
के लिए ऐसी चीज बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग होती है
वो देखेंगे हम यहां पे ऐसे यूआरएल नॉट
फाउंड ये कौन सा यूआरएल है एडमन सीएसआर
बढ़िया यार सॉरी दिस पेज अंडर मेंटेनेंस
नाइस
नाइस ले सकते हैं
यह यू डोंट हैव द एक्सेस यह देखो यह
बढ़िया है एक्सेस डिनाइड आ रहा है भाई यह
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग हो सकता है एक्सेस
डिनाइड एक्सेस नाइड ये सब हम बाद में बात
करेंगे कैसे एक्से डिनाइड का कितना
बेनिफिट है कितना मजा आता है आपको ये
देखिए 404 आ रही है
इसका हम सी नेम देख सकते हैं कितने कहां
पर जा रहा है सब डोमन टेकओवर के लिए काफी
अच्छी चीज हैय अभी हम देखेंगे अभी तो
डायरेक्ट बूट फोर्स करेंगे य
पर यह सप का द सर्वर डिड नॉट ऑथराइज द
रिक्वेस्ट 403 आ रहा है नॉट
फाउंड नाइस फोर विडेन
नाइस य कुछ अकाउंट बनाने का है अकाउंट का
है कुछ लॉगइन का है न नो
परमिशन
ओके एंड एरर ऑर्ड ये क्या आ रहा है नॉट
फंड अनसपोर्टेड डाटा और व्हाट एवर इनके सी
नेम्स को हम देखेंगे इनके हम सीम्स को
देखेंगे ठीक है इनके हम सी नेम्स को
देखेंगे नॉट अवेलेबल नॉट अवेलेबल डीएनएस
फेलियर ठीक है रिजल्ट को जीरो रिजल्ट जीरो
जेसन फॉर्मेट में था
हमारा हां फर नॉट फाउंड नो परमिशन टू
एक्सेस क्या है ये हैज बीन रिमूव्ड हैड
नेम चेंज ये ना सब डोमेन टेकओवर के लिए ये
सारी चीजें अच्छी है
देखने में अच्छी लग रही है मुझे इसको हम
देखेंगे अभी क्लाउड फ्रंट का लग रहा है
मुझे
ओके लेट्स सी सम मोर नथिंग
हियर कुछ नहीं है यहां पे ठीक है फर विडेन
ओके हां यह क्या है न्यूज
रूम ओके ब्लॉगस का य फर बहुत सारे फॉर
बिडेन है यार कुछ ना कुछ चलो मैं आगे आपको
आगे के सेशन में बताऊंगा ये फॉर बिडेन
वगैरह का क्या किस तरीके से करना है क्या
आप कर सकते हो सब चीज बताऊंगा नॉट फाउंड आ
रहा है यहां पे एंड एंड एंड एंड टेक्ड कडर
ए वेब एआई ठीक है अच्छी बात है एंड कौन सा
मिला हमें
टेंप . samsung.com ब ओके ठीक
है इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें तो हमें मिल रही है
इसको हम और भी चीज देखेंगे करके कुछ बाहर
का ये देखो ये क्या है व्ट इज
दिस ओके क्लियर र ओके ये कुछ हेल्प फाइल
है अनऑथराइज्ड है 403 यह सेम चीज है ठीक
है तो इस तरीके से हमें यहां पे आउटपुट्स
मिल है हमें स्क्रीनशॉट्स मिल रही है चलिए
अच्छी बात है य बहुत सारे स्क्रीनशॉट्स आ
गए मेरे ख्याल
से कितने आ गए यहां
पे ओ 89 स्क्रीनशॉट आ गए तो ये स्क्रीनशॉट
आपके लेते जाएगा स्क्रीनशॉट को हम एनालाइज
करेंगे मैं स्क्रीनशॉट एनालिसिस के ऊपर एक
डिटेल और भी तरीका मैं आपको बताऊंगा बहुत
सारी चीज बताऊंगा टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है
फिलहाल 90 ही ओनली स्क्रीनशॉट हुए हैं ठीक
है अब इसको देखो 90 हु है ना इसको अगर
थ्रेड को बढ़ाएंगे ना तो थोड़ा ये फास्ट
होता है जैसे थ्रेड को 100 से मैंने 500
कर दिया मान लो देखो बहुत ज्यादा भी नहीं
बढ़ाना है लेकिन ठीक है अभी करके एक बार
देख ले ट्राई मारते हैं देखते हैं कितना
कुछ फास्ट हो रहा है कि नहीं अब देखो ये
स्टार्ट करेगा तो थोड़ा फास्ट करने की
कोशिश करेगा बट 500 बहुत ज्यादा है 300 के
आसपास रखो उतना भी काम चल जाएगा आपका तो
ये ट्राई करेगा थोड़ा फास्ट करने का तो
फास्ट आपकी स्क्रीनशॉट होगी थ्रेड बढ़ाओ
फास्ट थोड़ा स्क्रीनशॉट होगा ठीक है चलो
ये तो काम हो गया अब इसको बंद कर देते हैं
अब
अब यहां पर बारी आती है डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्स की डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स करने के
लिए आपको मैं मेनली दो टूल बता रहा हूं आप
अपनी मर्जी से कोई सा भी टूल यूज कर सकते
हैं एक तो डब्लू फज भी आप यूज कर सकते हैं
डायरेक्ट रि ब्यूट फोर्सिंग के लिए
बेसिकली इट आल्सो गुड गुड टूल डब्लू फज बट
जो सबसे बढ़िया टूल्स मुझे लगते हैं वह है
आपके एफएफ यूएफ एंड आपकी डीआई आर सर्च ये
दो टूल हम यूज करेंगे थ्रू आउट द बग बाउंट
जर्नी अपने एंड इससे हम डायरेक्टली
सर्चिंग करेंगे ठीक है चलिए अब सबसे पहले
हम बात करते हैं एफएफ यूएफ की कि एफएफ
यूएफ कैसे काम करता है किस तरीके से ठीक
है समझ में आ रहा है काफी लोग यहां से
देखो काफी लोग देखो देखो काफी लोग चले गए
हैं पता है आज अभी लाइव सेशन में क्योंकि
कुछ एरर आ गई थी इस वजह से वो बेचारे झेल
नहीं पाए उस एरर को बात सबसे बड़ी बात ये
हो जाती है ना एरर को झेलना है एरर को
आपको सीखना है समझना है एक सेकंड रुक जाइए
गाइस जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट लेट मी
स्टार्ट ले स्टार्ट द सेशन
चलिए हां तो अब यहां पर एफएफ यूफ का हम
यूज करने वाले हैं भैया समझ में आ रहा है
ठीक है हां आप गो बस्टर यूज कर लो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं गो बस्टर भी यूज कर लो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है व्ट एवर कोई देखो
मैं एक चीज बता रहा हूं यार आप लोग पूछते
हो ना ये टूल यूज कर लो वो टूल यूज कर लो
मैं आपको समझाता हूं यूज देखो अरे यार आप
कोई सा भी टूल यूज करो बग बाउंट में नो
मैटर
कोई सा भी टूल आपके अकॉर्डिंग अच्छी काम
करनी चाहिए आपके आपको उसमें मजा आना चाहिए
एंड आपके अकॉर्डिंग वो परफेक्टली अगर आपको
रिजल्ट दे रहा है आउटपुट दे रहा है सब कुछ
सही से काम करर है यूज दैट टूल आप ये मत
बोलो कि ये यूज करना है कि नहीं यूज नहीं
आप अपने हिसाब से करो मेरे को ये दो टूल
अच्छे लगते हैं मैं आपको ये टूल आपको बता
रहा हूं आपको अल्टरनेट टूल्स भी मैंने
आपको बताए बाकी सब बहुत सारी चीजें
बताऊंगा गो बर आप कर सकते हो डी काली में
ल इनबिल्ट आपके टूर है डीआई आर बी ये
देखिए डीआई बीडीआर बर आप इसको यूज कर सकते
हो गो बर गो में रिटन टूल है उसको यूज कर
सकते हो आप डीआर सर्च यूज कर सकते हो आप
यू कैन आल्सो यूज लाइक एफएफ यूएफ जो अभी
मैं बताने जा रहा हूं आप वो यूज कर सकते
हो आप मल्टीपल टूल्स भैया यूज कर सकते हो
उसके कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है जो आपके लिए
बेस्ट हो आप वो यूज टूल यूज कीजिए ठीक
है इतना लेट नोटिफिकेशन मैंने नहीं भेजा
भाई होगा 10000 सब्सक्राइबर्स पे कुछ
स्पेशल तो होगा 10000 सब्सक्राइबर्स प कुछ
कुछ तो स्पेशल करेंगे है ना चलिए तो यहां
पे अब करते हैं एफएफ यूएफ अब यहां पे कैसे
करना है एफएफ यूएफ के लिए तो हान ए दे
देते हैं यहां पे देखो यहां पे जब नीचे
आओगे तुम यहां पे आओगे तो ये तुम्हें दिख
रहा होगा फज फाइल पाथ फ्रॉम .
txt.gz डायरेक्टरी बूट फोर्स के लिए ना एक
अच्छा वर्डलिस्ट निकालते हैं वर्डलिस्ट
कहां से निकाल लेंगे तो अ क्या है अ चलिए
हान यूएसआर शेयर वर्डलिस्ट एंड देखते हैं
र बी से ले लेते हैं डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्स से ले लेते हैं या डब्लू फथ से ले
लो कोई से भी ले लो र बी से ही ले लेते
हैं अ र बी एंड इसमें ले लेते हैं कौन
सी बिग एकटी बिग .
txt.gz अब वर्डलिस्ट के बाद आपको अपना
यूआरएल दे देना है जिसको आपको फज करना है
तो हमने यहां पे वर्डलिस्ट दे दिया अब
यहां पे यूआरएल या यूआरएल की लिस्ट आप जो
भी देना चाहते हो वो वो यूआरएल के लिस्ट
आप दे दीजिए या यूआरएल दे दीजिए व्हाट एवर
तो यहां पे आप जब जाएंगे ऊपर में यहां पे
देखिए यहां पे ऊपर में जाइए ऊपर में जाइए
यहां पे सबसे ऊपर चलते हैं यहां पे फज ठीक
है अब जब यू विल कम डाउन यहां से तो ये
टारगेट यूआरएल आपको दिखा रहा है एक टारगेट
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट यूआरएल के लिए अगर आपको
करना है तो न य आप लगा सकते हैं एंड आप
उसके बाद यूआरएल को में कर सकते हैं तो यह
क्या करेगा आपकी पूरी की पूरी जो यूआरएल
की जो भी सब डोमस जो भी डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्स है वो करके और आपके सामने लाकर दे
देगा अब यह उस केस में सबसे बढ़िया है उस
केस में अच्छा है जब आप एक पर्टिकुलर
यूआरएल को बहुत अच्छे से टारगेट कर रहे
हैं पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल को टारगेट करने की
कोशिश कर रहे हैं जैसे अब मेरे पास क्या
है मेरे पास देखो कौन सी है
अ लाइव है
ये हमारे पास फाइनल कौन सी बनी हुई थी
[संगीत]
samsung.com ये वाली तो हमने इसको यहां पर
कॉपी कर लिया कॉपी कर लिया अब हमने इसको
पास किया कहां पर फज एफएफ यूएफ में एंड
हमने इसको यहां पर
सॉरी य क्या
हुआ यहां पर एक ऐड आ गई यहां पे व्ट
हैपेंड ओके चलिए यह शायद
कुछ पता नहीं यह कुछ हो गया था अभी
टर्मिनल
में
टर्मिनल ओपन कर लेते हैं एफएफ यूएफ में
चलते हैं अगेन सेम कमांड लाते हैं कहां ग
एफएफ
यूएफ यार चलिए एफएफ
यूएफ यहां पे हान डब् वर्डलिस्ट लगा देते
हैं यूएसआर के अंदर शेयर के अंदर डीआर बी
के अंदर में एंड देन हम चलते हैं
डायरेक्टर
बी ओके डीआरबी में हमने कौन-कौन सी है
वर्ड लिस्ट है एंड यहां पे बिग डटी एक्सटी
ले लेते हैं बिगड t एक्टी बढ़िया अब हम
यहां पर हान य देके यहां पर यूआरएल को
मेंशन कर देते
हैं यूआरएल मेंशन करते ही यह हैंग क्यों
हो रहा है मुझे यह समझ नहीं आ रही है
बात एक काम करते
हैं लेट्स डू वन थिंग इसको एपीआई इसको
डायरेक्टली हम राइट डाउन ही कर देते हैं
यल क्या थी हमारी एड samsung.com ए
https.com राइट सो लेट्स पुट इट हियर तो
इसको ऐसे पुट करते
हैं यहां पे ठीक है एफएफ यूएफ कर देते हैं
एंड देन नड से वर्डलिस्ट डाल देते हैं य
आर शेयर डीआरबी एंड देन हम वर्डलिस्ट एंड
देन बिगड t एकटी डाल देते हैं ठीक है हमने
t बिगड t एकटी डाल दी उसके बाद न u डाल
देते हैं एंड यहां प डाल देते हैं एए
कॉलन एड
samsung.com यह हमने डाल दिया एआई
samsung.com फज जहां पे हमें फज करना है
ये हमने डाल दिया ठीक है
दैट्ची मैचिंग स्टेटस कोड कौन-कौन से होने
चाहिए जो आपको चाहिए कि भैया यह मैचिंग
स्टेटस कोड्स वाले हमारे पास रिजल्ट आए ए
200 हमने लगा दिया और एंटर कर देंगे एंटर
करेंगे ये स्टार्ट कर देगा फर्ज करना एंड
इट विल गिव यू ऑल द डायरेक्टरीज जिसके
स्टेटस कोर्स 200 है जो इस पर्टिकुलर सब
डोमेन पे आपके मिलेंगे इस टूल को एफएफ
यूएफ को ये इसकी खासियत है इस तरीके से ये
पर्टिकुलर को बहुत बढ़िया से करता है बहुत
शानदार तरीके से ये फज करेगा ओके तो ये
आपको वेट करना है जैसे आपने फजिंग स्टार्ट
कर दी वेट अब देखो एक मैं डिफरेंस आपको
बता देता हूं एक चीज आपको बता देता हूं ये
जो स्पीड देख रहे हो इसकी 36 रिक्वेस्ट पर
सेकंड आ रही है ना 36 रिक्वेस्ट पर सेकंड
30 रिक्वेस्ट पर सेकंड अब इसमें वीपीएस
यूज करोगे ना 20 3 रिक्वेस्ट पर सेकंड ऐसे
भी जाएगी 100 100 150 रिक्वेस्ट 200
रिक्वेस्ट पर सेकंड और यह बहुत फास्ट होगी
बहुत फास्ट कभी-कभी तो यहां भी थोड़ा
ज्यादा हो जा रहा है बट स्टिल यह वीपीएस प
बहुत फास्ट एंड एकदम रेगुलर बेसिस प आपकी
उस वो स्पीड मेंटेन रहेगी और बहुत जल्दी
आपको रिजल्ट मिलते हैं तो ये डायरेक्ट बूट
फोर्स करोगे अब डायरेक्ट बूट फोर्स करने
का रीजन क्या होता है वेब साइट जो होती है
हमारी वेबसाइट या सब डोमेन या डोमेन जो भी
होता है वहां पे बहुत सारी ऐसी डोमेन होती
है जहां एक पर्टिकुलर वेब पेज पे कोई
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन होती है कोई
पर्टिकुलर वेब पेज पे कोई हिडन इंफॉर्मेशन
होती है या कोई जूसी इंफॉर्मेशन होता है
जो हमें फाइंड करना होता है वही हम
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स के थ्रू हम हर एक
पॉसिबल जो पेज है उसको ब्रूट फोर्स करते
हैं पॉसिबल पेज का मतलब यहां पे जैसे कि
ये जितने वर्डलिस्ट में पेजेस है ना वर्ड
लिस्ट के अंदर जो भी एंट्रीज है उसको ये
फेच कर रहा है जैसे इसका मतलब क्या है
जैसे मैं आपको बता देता हूं जैसे हम
यूएसआर में देखो चलो यूएसआर में चलते हैं
शेयर में चलते हैं अ वर्डलिस्ट के अंदर
चलते हैं जो वर्डलिस्ट हम यूज कर रहे हैं
उसके अंदर चलते हैं डीआर बी के अंदर चलते
हैं एंड यहां कॉमन डॉ नहीं कौन सा यूज कर
रहे हम बिगड एक्टी यूज कर रहे हैं राइट
इसको हम ओपन कर लेते हैं बिगड बहुत बड़ी
है तो यह जो डायरेक्टरीज आपको दिख रही है
ना इसका मतलब ये सबको एक्सप्लोर कर रहा है
इसका मतलब क्या हो जाता है ना देखो इसका
मतलब क्या होता है मैं आपको समझा देता हूं
जैसे यह यहां पर यह दिख रही है तुम्हें
डॉट
एचटी एक्सेस ये फाइल दिख रही है ड एटी
एक्सेस
यह डॉट एसटी एक्सेस एक एक एक वड लिस्ट है
ये इसका मतलब क्या हुआ ना कि यह डॉट
एक्सटी एक्सेस को उस पर्टिकुलर सब डोमेन
के आगे लगा के चेक करेगा कि ये फाइल वहां
प्रेजेंट है या नहीं है दिस इ सेंसिटिव
फाइल एंड ये हमारे काम का हो सकता है हो
सकता है हमारे किसी यूज का हो सकता है इस
तरीके से डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग होती
है और व चेक करता है बस यही काम करता है
और तो कुछ है नहीं राइट तो अभी यह बहुत
बड़ी फाइल है इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं यहां
पर कुछ मिला क्या
इनको इट गट नथिंग कुछ यहां मिला नहीं यहां
पे कुछ मिला नहीं इसको राइट अब इसी के साथ
एक और टूल है जो डायरेक्ट बट फोर्सिंग के
लिए काफी कमाल का है डीआर
सर्च यह वाली टूल इसको यूज करने के लिए
कैसे करना है एप्ट इंस्टॉल डीआई आर सर्च
एंटर कर देना ये इंस्टॉलेशन चालू हो जाएगी
इंस्टॉल आपका हो जाएगा मेरा ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल्ड है यहां पे ठीक है तो यह आ रहा
है इस तरीके से अब इसको यूज करने के लिए
डी सर्च हान h कर लीजिएगा इसके हेल्प फाइल
दिखा देगी इसमें सबसे अच्छी बात है देखो
यहां पे हान यहां पे आप पूरी जो हमारे पास
लिस्ट है हम सबको एक साथ इंक्लूड करने
वाले हैं कैसे करने वाले
हैं डीआई आर सर्च हान ए यह देखो ऊपर
जाओ हान एल से यूआरएल पाथ यूआरएल लिस्ट जो
है आपके पास उसकी पाथ आपको दे देनी है ठीक
है तो हमने यहां पे न ए दिया यरल पा जो है
samsung-ro ये हान एल से दे दिया पाथ ठीक
है अब हमें क्या यूज करना है न e हमें
कौन-कौन से एक्सटेंशंस वेबसाइट वाले जो है
वो यूज करने हैं तो पीएचपी की वेबसाइट्स
के लिए ट्राई करना है एसपी के लिए यूज
करना है या जो भी वेबसाइट है जिस टाइप की
वेबसाइट्स के लिए आपको लगता है कि इसके
पास ये सारी वेबसाइट्स इंक्लूडेड होंगी
samsungmobile.com हम बैकअप वाली या जावा
भी दे सकते हैं अगर आपको चाहिए तो बट हम
एचटीएल फिलहाल इतना रहने देते हैं ठीक है
तो हमने क्या किया हमने हमने एक्सटेंशन को
भी यहां पे बता दिया चलिए एक्सटेंशन हमने
दे दिया अब चलिए अब वेट
कीजिए बता दूंगा मैं बता दूंगा सब मैं
बताऊंगा टेंशन नहीं लेने का भाई सब
बताऊंगा मैं आपको वीपीएस ओपीस सबका
बताऊंगा टेंशन मत लो ठीक है टेंशन नहीं
लेना है बस लाइक ठोक दो फटाफट लाइक ठोको
जरा यार एक बार मस्त वाला है चलिए ठीक है
तो यूआरएल हमने दे दिया पाथ दे दिया हमने
एक्सटेंशन दे दिया अब यहां पे मुझे
अ थ्रेड देना है आप थ्रेड दे दीजिए हान t
लगा के अगर आप थ्रेडिंग करना चाहते हैं
थ्रेड कर दीजिए थोड़ा बढ़ा दीजिए कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है ब्रूट फोर्स करना
है रिकसिवली तो आप कर सकते हैं फिलहाल
हमें जरूरत नहीं है अब यहां हान आई
इंक्लूड स्टेटस कोड्स तो कौन-कौन से
स्टेटस कोड्स इंक्लूड करने हैं तो हान आ
दे दीजिए मुझे बस 200 वाले इंक्लूड करने
हैं बस
दैट्ची 4 भी ते इंक्लूड हमने कर दिया
एक्सक्लूड करना है तोन लगा सकते हैं बसट्स
इट ओके नथिंग एल्स नथिंग एल्स कुछ और तो
है नहीं
य टर के साथ आप इसको यूज कर सकते हैं
प्रॉक्सी के लिए आप यू कैन यूज द टर आल्सो
अगर आप इसके साथ टर यूज करना चाहते आप ट
यूज कर सकते
हैं ओके
बस बाकी कुछ है नहीं यहां पे वी आर गुड टू
गो तो हमने इतना कर दिया एंड ट्स इट अब हम
यहां पे एंटर करेंगे अब इस
samsung.in डब् लगा के यह देखिए यहां पे
एक टैग है यहां पे
वेर कहीं ना कहीं ऊपर में आपको मिल जाएगा
नड वड लिस्ट
का इसमें देख लीजिएगा वर्डलिस्ट या हान
डब् करके आपको मिल जाएगा ठीक है तो आप अलग
से भी वड लिस्ट लगा सकते हैं शायद नीचे ही
मिलल जाएगा शायद कहीं
प कहीं पर दिख रहा है क्या वड लिस्ट
का
यह मुझे नहीं दिख रहा है किसी को नहीं दिख
रहा यह रहा लिस्ट नड ठीक है तो आप
वर्डलिस्ट लगा के उसका पा दे सकते हैं एंड
वो पर्टिकुलर वो वर्ड लिस्ट यूज करेगा तो
अ ये देखिए यहां पे जैसे इसने फाइंड किया
एक हेल्थ करके इस वाले सब डोमेन प एक फाइल
है हेल्थ करके तो हम इसको देख सकते हैं
जैसे हमने क्या
किया कॉपी किया एंड लेट्स ट्राई टू ओपन इट
यहां पेस्ट कर देते हैं एंड कौन सा लोकेशन
है एच एल टी एच जड हेल्स ठीक है तो इस पे
हम ट्राई करते हैं एच इ ए एल टी एच जड
हेल्स तो हेल्स पे क्या है मतलब ये देखना
है हमें ये देखो अलाइव ठीक है ये मतलब
हेल्थ हेल्थ क्या बता रहा है और कुछ नहीं
तो ये अलाइव है ठीक है अच्छी बात है तो ये
इस तरीके से चेक करेगा अ चलिए यह तो एक
बार यह वाली सब डोमेन चल है अब यहां पे
थोड़ी सी थ्रेडिंग हम बढ़ा देते हैं मान
लो बंद करते हैं
इसको इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं इसको हम
थोड़ा थ्रेड बढ़ा देते हैं लेट्स इंक्रीज
द
थ्रेड डी
सर्च हान एच यहां पर हम थ्रेड को बढ़ाएंगे
थ्रेड को कितना रख देंगे क्या है हमारा
हाइन थ्रेड है ना या हान टी
है रिकसिव है हाइन टी है तो नंबर थ्रेड्स
को बढ़ाते हैं 25 आ रहे थे डिफॉल्ट तो नटी
को 25 को 100 कर देते हैं थोड़ा फास्ट हो
जाएगा आपका जो आपका यह जो रिजल्ट आपको
आएगा मिलेगा यह थोड़ा सा यह फास्ट प्रोसेस
होगा तो आपको थोड़ी जल्दी रिजल्ट्स जो है
वो मिलनी शुरू हो जाएंगी तो यह क्या हो
रहा है
भाई यह मैंने एफएफ यूएफ में कर दिया यहां
डायरेक्टरी सर्च डीर सर्च प करना है
में यह रही राइट तो यहां पे थ्रेडिंग का
देख लेते हैं हाइन टी ही होगा शायद से
हाइन टी ही है नंबर थ्रेड्स के लिए तो
हाइन टी ही लगा देते हैं
हान t एंड इसको हम 100 कर देते हैं ठीक है
तो अब हम देखते हैं यहां पे अब ये जो
रिजल्ट्स आएंगे 100 थ्रेट्स के साथ आएंगे
थोड़ा सा फास्ट आपके रिजल्ट आपको देखने को
मिलेगा फास्ट जो है वो यहां पे ये करेगा
सर्च ओके तो ये डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
हो रही है अब डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स भी
जब आप क्लाउड में करेंगे तो ये काफी
ज्यादा काफी ज्यादा फास्ट आपका होगा एंड
काफी मजा आएगा क्लाउड में यही है कि आपको
बहुत फास्ट रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे तो बहुत मजा
आएगा अब देखो अच्छा मुझे ये बताओ सच सच
बताओ सभी लोग मुझे बताओ आपको नहीं लगता कि
जब हम ये चीजें कर रहे हैं अ जब हम लोकल
सिस्टम पे यह कर रहे हैं तो बहुत स्लो चल
रहा है थोड़ा सा मजा कम आएगा ऐसा लग रहा
है आपको थोड़ा स्लो चल रहा है आर यू
गेटिंग इट्स लिटिल बिट स्लो स्लो लग रहा
है आप लोगों को कि नहीं लग रहा कि सही लग
रहा है आप लोगों को
बताइए बता दीजिए स्लो लग रहा है कि नहीं
लग रहा आप लोगों को यह
चीज लग रहा है
स्लो
चलिए ये एक का डायरेक्ट रूट फोर्स हो गया
अब दूसरे का यह कर रहा है अब यहां पर 200
में जो जो पाथ मिलेंगे उन पाथ पर जाकर
आपको देखना है कि पॉसिबल कुछ ऐसा कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ तो है कि नहीं डायरेक्ट
वोट फोर्स का यही काम है एंड यह हम
देखेंगे अभी आगे चलके और हम जब वीपीएस में
करेंगे तो थोड़ा फास्ट देखेंगे जैसे देखिए
इसने 404 वाले भी फाइंड किए बहुत सारे
देखो 404
वाले देख रहे
हो है
ना
अच्छा वीपीएस आपको चाहिए भाई वीपीएस है
ना देखो यह कुछ 404 वाले पाथ है इसलिए 404
को हटा दोगे तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यह 404
है जो पहले कहीं होंगे बट अब नहीं
है आप में से किसी के पास है एडब्ल्यू एस
का
अकाउंट किसी के पास है एडब्ल्यू एस अकाउंट
का क्लाउड है आपके पास अकाउंट है आप लोगों
के पास किसी के पास भी है फ्री टियर वाला
या कोई सा
भी जय श्री राम नितेश सर टर्स की जल रही
है हां भाई जल रही सही बात बोला बिल्कुल
सही
बोला हां फास्ट होगा तो और मजा आएगा राइट
स्लो होगा तो थोड़ा सा स्लो ही रहेगा किसी
के पास भी है एडब्ल्यू एस एनी
वन तानिया के पास है बढ़िया तानिया अच्छी
बात है आपके पास है तो ग्रेट अन का
बढ़िया जैसे मैं आपको बताऊंगा कैसे क्या
करना है मेरे पास भी एडब्ल्यू एस पड़ा
होगा पड़ा है एड्स आई हैव आल्सो एड्स
अकाउंट राइट तो मैं आपको वैसे साइन इन
करता हूं एक बार कुछ इस तरह का एड्स का
आपका कंसोल जो है वो आपको यहां पर दिखेगा
इस तरीके
से
यह ये एड्स यहां प आपको दिख जाएगा इस
तरीके से ठीक है एडब का कंसोल आपको जब
होगा तो यहां पे आपको क्या है ट के
इंस्टेंसस लच करने पड़ेंगे यहां पे ट के
में आके आप इंस्टेंस लच करोगे ट के अंदर
में फिलहाल के लिए फिलहाल हमारा ये
इंस्टेंस चल रहा है अभी फिलहाल के लिए दो
इंस्टेंस चल रहे हैं कुछ हमारा प्रोजेक्ट
चल रहा है हमारा तो उसका ये इंस्टेंस आपको
दिख रहा होगा यहां प ठीक है और कोई और कुछ
नहीं है तो इसमें और भी सेंसेस चला के हम
क्लाउड में सेटअप करेंगे हम मशीन को
इंस्टॉल करेंगे तो मजा आएगा फिर उसमें हम
कॉन्फिन करेंगे और भी चीजें करेंगे तो ये
मैं आपको बताऊंगा सिखाऊंगा मैं बी मोस्ट
प्रोबेबली नेक्स्ट क्लास में मैं ट्राई
करूंगा कि आपको ये चीज समझा देने का अच्छे
से कैसे आप काली वगैरह भी चला सकते हो या
यवन टू पे आप कर सकते हो हालांकि जनरली
यवन टू लोग यूज करते हैं अ क्योंकि यवन टू
भी डेवियन बेस्ड है तो सब कुछ आपका बढ़िया
से काम करेगा काली की रिपोजिटरी आप ऐड भी
कर सकते हो उसमें तो सब परफेक्ट काम करेगा
तो बस यहां पे फिर मशीन चलेगी बहुत ही
फास्ट चलेगी फिर मजा आएगा आपको राइट बहुत
मजा आएगा
एडब्ल्यू में आपको फ्री में मिलता है फ्री
टियर जो है आपका एड्स का वो आप ले सकते
हैं वो आपको फ्री में ही मिलेगा ठीक है
एडब्ल्यू का जो आपको फ्री टियर होता है वो
फ्री में मिलता है उसमें कोई पैसा आपको
नहीं देना पड़ता है जैसे एडब्ल्यू एस फ्री
ट्रायल जो आप लीजिएगा तो आप फ्री ट्रायल
में जा सकते हैं यहां पे यह
वाला यह वाला आप जा सकते हैं एड फ्री
ट्रायल के लिए ठीक है इस पे आप जाके
अकाउंट क्रिएट कर सकते हैं यहां पे आपको
डेबिट कार्ड से आप कर सकते हैं डेबिट
कार्ड आपका यूज होगा लेकिन उस एक ध्यान
रखिएगा कि आप लिमिटेड ही यूज कीजिएगा मतलब
जो आपको लगे आपको समझ में आए तभी आप यूज़
कीजिएगा मैं आपको वैसे बता दूंगा सब कुछ
फ्री टेयर में क्या-क्या चीजें मिलती है
वो सब आपको पता चल जाएगा 750 आवर्स का ईसी
टू इंस्टेंस जो है वो पर मंथ मिलता है
आपको 12 महीनों के लिए 12 महीने तक फ्री
होती है 5gb के s3 बकेट आपको मिलता है
स्टोरेज मिलती है तो वो काफी है इतना आप
यूज भी नहीं कर रहे होंगे ठीक है बाकी और
चीजें जो है आपके ज्यादा कुछ यूज खास आने
वाली नहीं है ठीक है तो बाकी आपको मेन तो
आपका यही है 750 e2 वाली तो टी टू वाली जो
है ये आपको मिलनी चाहिए इतने आप करेंगे
एंड इसमें आपको क्या-क्या मिलेगा
lin3 माइक्रो के इंस्टेंसस है वो आपको
मिलेंगे ठीक है तो t2 t2 और t3 माइक्रो जो
है इसमें आप इंस्टेंसस चला सकते हैं आप
गा दो ₹ कटेंगे शायद एंड आपका ये फ्री
टायर बन जाएगा बट याद रखिएगा ज्यादा अगर
आप यूज केस कर रहे हैं इसके थ्रेस होल्ड
से मैं आपको बताऊंगा कैसे ना बिलिंग थ्रेस
होल्ड जो है ना उसको आपको अलर्ट स्टार्ट
कर देना है ताकि जैसे ही आप उससे बाहर जाए
तो आपको अलर्ट आ जाए और आप वहां से रोक दे
नहीं तो आपके चार्जेस बनने स्टार्ट हो
जाएंगे एंड चार्जेस बनने स्टार्ट हो
जाएंगे तो आपको वो पैसे पे करने पड़
जाएंगे सबसे बड़ी बात ये हो जाती है तो ये
थोड़ी दिक्कत वाली बात है ठीक है बाकी
इसके कुछ तरीके हैं मैं आपको ट्राई करूंगा
बताने का ऑन द
एंड डेनिक्स अकेडमी ए एप्लीकेशन के थ्रू
भी कुछ ट्रिक्स आपको बता सकता हूं मैं
बाकी सेटअप करके बताऊंगा सब कुछ एंड आपको
एक चीप अल्टरनेटिव बताऊंगा बहुत ही चीप
सस्ता अल्टरनेटिव आपको बताऊंगा आप वहां से
भी ले सकते हैं आप क्लाउड जो अपनी जो मशीन
है वो ले सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
राइट
चलिए तो यहां चलते हैं डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग हो रही है एंड यहां पे ये
फालतू के पथ्स है इतने सारे जो मिल रहे
हैं आपको सेम आपको ये आपको जो मिल रहा है
लेंथ मिल रही है आपको सेम 620 बा यानी कुछ
यहां पर कुछ खास डिफरेंट है नहीं यहां पे
ठीक है जैसे यहां पर कुछ मिला है ओपन आईडी
कॉन्फिन 2kb का यह हम देख सकते
हैं दिस इज गुड ओपन आईडी
कॉन्फिन अकाउंट samsung.com पे तो यह वाली
चीज एक थोड़ी सी सही लग रही है मुझे तो
इसको हम यहां से कॉपी कर लेते हैं
[संगीत]
एंड किस वाले डोमेन प चल रहा है
यह samsung.com
ठीक है तो इस पर एक बार चल लेते
हैं एंड लेट्स सी कि कुछ है क्या यहां
पे ओके सो कुछ यहां पर क्या है
ये टोकन ओके पेयर वाइज ओके पब्लिक ठीक है
ठीक है इंफो ओके इंफो है ये नथिंग एल्स
कुछ कुछ लीकेज नहीं है ऑथराइजेशन कोड ओके
बट लीकेज कुछ नहीं है गाइज
[संगीत]
अ
ओके ओके ओके वी गॉट सम रिजल्ट्स बट देयर
इज नो सच लीकेज कोई लीकेज ऐसी कुछ खास है
नहीं बट अगर कुछ लीकेज होती टोकन होगन अगर
कुछ ऐसा होता तो फिर मजा आ जाता राइट ये
एक मिला हमें एट l j जसन फॉर्मेट है ये
जेसन इसको भी हम देख सकते हैं कि क्या है
यहां पे ये सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी यह क्या
[संगीत]
आया नो कर देते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां
पे मैं देता हूं यह
वाली ओके लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी क्या है
ये ओके एंड ए का है यह कुछ
समथिंग एंड दिस इ इ 256 फिंगरप्रिंट ठीक
है कौन सी पैकेज है यार ये कौन सी ऐप की
है दिस पप इज इस ऐप का है कुछ
ये लेट सी गॉट
समथिंग ये रही इफ यू आर अ फन यूजर यू मे
हैव सेवर सीन साइन इन ऑन योर स्क्रीन आर
यू यू आर राइट गेट आंसर हियर ठीक है द इज
अ सिस्टम प डिजाइन फॉर एंड्र
यहां पे कुछ खास नहीं है अ यहां पे कुछ
मिला एरर नहीं कुछ भी नहीं है एरर है
हेल्थ जो है ठीक है ये इक्सड एटीए क्या है
ये ठीक है ये तो इंडेक्स पेज है भाई और
कुछ एनीथिंग एल्स नहीं एनीथिंग और कुछ
नहीं है मतलब ये चल रहा है ये चल रहा है
अभी इसको हम देखेंगे भाई इसको जब हम उस पे
करेंगे तब देखेंगे बहुत कुछ मिल सकता है
भाई जब
तुम फर्ज करोगे ना जब तुम डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्स तो तुम्हें मजा आ जाएगा
तुम्हें जब तुम क्लाउड में फर्ज करोगे ठीक
है दैट इट
दैट्ची रहने देते हैं आई होप यू एंजॉयड द
सेशन अगर आपको सेशन अच्छा लगा तो मुझे
बताइए एंड अगर आप डिजिटल फॉरन सिक्स में
काफी कुछ करना चाहते हैं डिजिटल फॉरन
सिक्स को एक्सप्लोर करना चाहते हैं तो
डिजिटल फॉरन सिक्स हमारा जो अभी लाइव
ट्रेनिंग स्टार्ट हुआ है आप उसको जवाइन कर
सकते हैं एंड यू कैन ऑन बोर्ड दैट बिफोर
नेक्स्ट वन वीक क्योंकि ये अभी ऑफर में
आपको ऑन बोर्डिंग आपकी हो जाएगी आप उसमें
प्री बुक कर पाएंगे उसकी जो लिंक है मैंने
ऑलरेडी आपको दे दिया था आई होप कि आपको
लिंक मिल गया होगा एंड आप पहले मुझे चैट
में बता दीजिए कैसा लगा आपको आज का सेशन
हाउ यू अ हाउ वाज द सेशन एंड डिड यू एंजॉय
द सेशन मजा आया आपको सेशन में एंजॉय करा
आपने जल्दी बता दीजिए जल्दी फटाफट फटाफट
फटाफट बताइए फटाफट फटाफट
फटाफट डिड यू एंजॉय द सेशन गाइज
डिस्ट लिंक मैंने ड है
ओके ओके बस यह आज का टास्क मैंने यही दे
दिया आपको पहले ही दे दिया था टास्क आपको
एक ही टास्क है ट्राई टू फाइंड सब डोम ऑफ
सब एस मेनी ऑफ एस मेनी यू कैन एंड डू
डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्स डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्स ऑन सब डोमेन ऑन ऑन सम सब डोमस
कुछ सब डोमस प अच्छे सब डोमस प आप
डायरेक्टरी रूट फोर्स कीजिएगा यही टास्क
है आज का एंड आप
ओके थैंक यू सलिस थैंक यू सो मच आपको
अच्छा लगा थैंक यू
लाइक ओके वेबसाइट पर जाओ आपको सिलेबस की
पीडीएफ मिल जाएगी ब्रदर वेबसाइट पर जाइए
सिलेबस की पीडीएफ आपको मिल जाएगी ठीक
है ओके तो थैंक यू सो मच एवरीबॉडी फॉर
जॉइनिंग द सेशन एंड मेकिंग इट वंडरफुल आप
अपने दोस्तों को भी शेयर कीजिए सेशन को
क्योंकि जितना शेयर करेंगे जितना आप शेयर
करेंगे जितना हमारे हमारे यहां इंगेजमेंट
बढ़ती जाएगी मुझे उतना ही मजा आएगा सेशन
को लेने में एंड जैसे-जैसे आपकी इंगेजमेंट
कम होगी मेरी भी जो इनकरेज जो इनकरेज में
होता हूं वो कम होती जाएगी इनकरेजमेंट कम
हो जाएगी एंड आपको फिर शायद प्रॉब्लम होगी
तो प्लीज आपके ऊपर मैंने बस इतना ही रखा
है शेयर कीजिए सेशन को अपने दोस्तों के
बीच को बताइए वीडियोस को शेयर कीजिए
कितने दिन में हो जाएंगे अभी
सब्सक्राइबर्स पता है कितने अभी हमारे जो
सब्सक्राइबर्स है करेंटली मैं आपको बता
रहा हूं जस्ट राइट
नाउ वी हैव 8430 सब्सक्राइबर्स ठीक है
8400 के आसपास मान के चलो 8400 और इसको 00
कब तक करा दोगे आप लोग बताओ आप लोग के हाथ
में है वैसे
भी चैनल आप लोग जवाइन कीजिए चैनल जॉइन
कीजिए वहीं पर सबको सेशन के बारे में पता
चलेगा उसके पहले कुछ नहीं पता
चलेगा थैंक यू
शलेश नेक्स्ट वीक
तक नेक्स्ट वीक ठीक है देखते हैं देखते
हैं लेट्स सी वो आप लोग शेयर करोगे चैनल
के बारे में लोगों को बताओगे स्प्रेड
करोगे तो जल्दी हो जाएगा बाकी देखते हैं
आज आ तारीख है 8 जनवरी अगर 14 जनवरी तक हो
जाए तो देखते हैं लेट्स सी पॉसिबल है कि
नहीं तो सबको टाटा बाय बाय एंड गुड नाइट
थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग एंड जाइए खाइए
पीजिए एंड एंजॉय